très bien bon mais ce collègue
je répète donc désolé tu quelques
et nous entendons ce matin monsieur
thomas fatto directeur général caisse
nationale de l'assurance maladie sur la
présentation du rapport charges et
produits et ce document fournit
traditionnellement quelques pistes sur
le plfss à venir et je me réjouis mais
ce fantôme que vous puissiez l'évoqué
cette année devant notre commission
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat est disponible en vidéo à la
demande et je salue ceux de nos
collègues qui participent à cette
réunion à distance et monsieur le
directeur général je vous laisse tout de
suite la parole
merci merci beaucoup à la présidente
bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
beaucoup de nous donner l'occasion en
effet au travers de cette audition de
vous présenter les grandes lignes du
rapport chargé et produit qui a été
adoptée par le conseil de la cnam la
semaine dernière et qui constitue je
dirais comme chaque année
je crois en tout cas une somme
relativement importante de travaux à la
phase de diagnostic et de
propositions
je vais essayer de pas être trop long
parce que le rapport est assez est assez
dense est assez riche et il faudrait
sans doute ceux beaucoup plus de temps
pour
faire des détails très précis de chacun
des éléments diagnostic et de
propositions néanmoins essayer peut-être
de survoler si j'ose dire des éléments
principaux de diagnostiquer 2 et deux
propositions on sait situer pour
préparer sur un port qui vous l'imaginez
nécessite un travail de plusieurs mois
dans un contexte qui qui finalement est
assis sur trois enseignements c'est
assez basique mais qu'il est utile de le
rappeler d'une part c'est que la crise
nous a rappelé en termes de sur
l'importance de la politique de santé
publique et de prévention sur lesquels
on fait beaucoup d'analysés proposition
deuxième élément le des enseignements à
tirer autour aussi des nouveaux modes
d'organisation des transformations pas
crise à sanitaire a pu générer
coopération public privé sur la
ranimation place de la téléconsultation
place des organisations territoriales
du système de santé changement des
compétences des professionnels sur les
tests et la vaccination et puis
troisième enseignement ça n'est pas le
le plus facile si j'ose dire évidemment
l'impact financier majeur de la crise de
déficit 2020-2021 historique de
l'assurance-maladie 30 milliards du puy
26 milliards d'euros et un déficit en
baisse en 2022 prévisionnel mais tout de
même rang corps troisième déficit le
plus élevé de l'histoire de l'assurance
maladie tout près de 20 milliards
d'euros donc évidemment un enjeu de
maintenir ou de reconstruire la
viabilité économique à long terme de
notre système de santé et d'assurance
maladie une fois qu'on a dit ça si j'ose
dire on s'est appuyé sur un travail qui
a la foi
a enrichi diagnostic habituel de charges
et produits et puis s'est construit
autour de différents fils rouges je
passe rapidement sur le diagnostic
simplement pour partager avec vous
j'espère que je peux me permettre vous
l'avez d'ores et déjà noter chaque année
depuis maintenant dix ans nous publions
ce que nous appelons notre cartographie
des dépenses d'assurance maladie
c'est-à-dire la présentation des
dépenses d'assurance maladie par
pathologie combien coûte le diabète
remet un coup tu le cancer et pas
seulement combien coûte quelle est la
prévalence comment se répartit la
dépense comment elle évolue comment a
évolué aussi les effectifs concernés on
a souhaité changer assez profondément sa
présentation cette année en ouvrant
cette cartographie au travers d'un outil
de data visualisation d'un site à mehdi
qui s'appelle amélie data pathologie et
qui permet à chacune et chacun d'eux
sans paraître ces données au travers
d'abord d'un outil data visualisation de
cartographie au niveau national
départemental régional c'est quoi la
prévalence du cancer dans mon
département dans ma région c'est qu'à
l'évolution des dépenses de diabète et
tous ces sujets là sont à la fois ouvert
à l'ensemble des citoyens est ouvert
également un open data puisque chacun
peut utiliser ces données faire des
travaux qu'il souhaite rapprocher des
données des comparaisons entre
départements entre régions entre
pathologie donc ça c'est le premier
élément très riche et et on a ouvert ce
site ya maintenant trois semaines et on
a d'ailleurs des mesures d'audience je
dirais extrêmement intéressante qui
montre l'intérêt de ce type d'outils et
je reviendrai je passais des questions
sur l'utilisation du smds je crois le
système national et dans une santé et un
des anciens des voilà les objets
d'utilisation de ce système de données
c'est de mettre à disposition de
l'ensemble des citoyens ce type
d'analysé deuxième élément diagnostic
vous trouverez dans le rapport
forme de cartographie de l'activité des
professionnels sont des professionnels
de santé libéraux sur le sur le
territoire français depuis 20 ans c'est
quoi et c'est un une cartographie qu'on
souhaite maintenant construire et mettre
à jour chaque année
quelle est la démographie des prochaines
de santé quelle est la densité quelle
est l'évolution de la répartition
territoriale quelle est leur activité
leur file active conte mais représentent
leurs prescriptions
quels sont leur secteur d'exercice pour
les médecins quel est le niveau de
dépassements d'honoraires tout ça n'est
pas fondamentalement nouveau mais chaque
année nous mettrons à jour cet
finalement ce panorama de l'activité des
professionnels de santé de ville et nous
réalisons certain nombre deux focus et
puis troisième élément d'enrichissement
du diagnostic nous avons construit un
tableau de bord des indicateurs de santé
publique de notre prix y compris pour
donner corps à l'idée que cette santé
publique et cette prévention on doit
avoir une place plus importante à la
fois dans sans doute l'action des
pouvoirs publics et dans le débat public
et donc vous trouverez là aussi c'est
nouveau ce tableau de bord des
indicateurs en 15 17 indicateurs de
santé publique qui montrent notamment
les progrès importants que nous avons à
réaliser sur les différents indicateurs
de prévention que ce soit primaire
secondaire ou tertiaire très rapidement
voilà madame la présidente un peu le
diagnostic enrichi ensuite nous avons
construit le rapport autour de
différents fils rouges fil rouge autour
d'eux d'abord de pathologies avec depuis
plusieurs années également le le rapport
charges et produits essaye de construire
des analyses et des propositions autour
d'eux non pas d'offre d'une offre de
soins identifier la ville l'hôpital
médico-social de médicaments mais autour
de pathologies comme on améliore la
prise en charge cette année du diabète
et comment aussi en tire les
enseignements des travaux que nous avons
menée l'année dernière sur
l'insuffisance cardiaque qui reviendrait
tout à leur deuxième fils rouges autour
d'une approche par population là aussi
pour toujours coup pareil pour essayer
d'aller plus loin que des approches par
offre de soins et nous avons cette année
travaillé sur le sujet de la maternité
et de la petite enfance quel est l'état
de santé des pardon de le dire comme ça
mais des femmes enceintes de notre pays
comment sont prises en charge des
enfants de 0 à 6 ans dans notre pays
quels sont les insuffisances les manques
et les avancées que nous pouvons pousser
troisième fil rouge autour de
l'organisation d'échouage d'évoquer avec
l'idée que l'on se situe bien sûr
quelques mois en amont à la fois de la
future négociation de la convention
médicale qui sera de nos sujets majeurs
à la rentrée à l'automne et puis bien
sûr aussi dans le cadre des réflexions
que le gouvernement devrait avoir autour
de l'organisation territoriale des soins
donc j'y reviendrai aussi différentes
propositions et était agnostique sur ce
sujet enfin bien sûr
j'avais dire sujet incontournable du
rapport charié produits le fil rouge
autour de l'efficience et de la maîtrise
des dépenses avec des propositions de
l'assurance maladie autour de 1 2
milliard d'euros sur lequel j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir très rapidement là
aussi si j'essaye sous votre contrôle en
a présenté je serai rapide 1 / perd
quelques quelques zooms si j'ose dire
sur quelques éléments importants que je
voulais partager sachant que je le redis
je vous ai adressé la semaine dernière
le rapport et idées en ligne il y à même
cette année une innovation majeure qui
est une synthèse des 400 pages du
rapport tout ce que vous voulez savoir
surcharge des produits en 20 pages mais
ça n'aurait évidemment ça ne vous
excusez pas de ne pas avoir de ne pas
dire le rapport cet été
tout cela sur des mineurs la synthèse le
rapport est donc peut-être quelques
quelques je dirais faits marquants ou
propositions marquante que je joue les
goûts d'une part sur l'insuffisance
cardiaque vous dire d'abord qu'on a
continué à mener un travail important
avec les acteurs sur le territoire pour
construire un diagnostic territorial de
la prise en charge de l'insuffisance
cardiaque parle à la fois la ville et
l'hôpital et pour construire de quatre
propositions d'une part
mener une grande campagne de
communication que nous ferons à la
rentrée pour mieux faire connaître les
signes d' alerte de l'insuffisance
cardiaque l'a4 signe d' alerte bien
identifiés par les sociétés savantes une
fatigue soudaine un essoufflement une
baisse de poids rapide et des oedèmes
voilà ces signaux là sont insuffisamment
connue de la population voire
éventuellement parfois deux du corps
médical nous ferons une grande campagne
de communication qu'on peut le faire sur
d'autres thèmes la grippe les
antibiotiques le dentaire à la rentrée
2022 deuxième sujet améliorer la prise
en charge à la sortie de l'hôpital pour
les patients insuffisants cardiaques
vous savez que depuis une dizaine
d'années nous développons des programmes
d'accompagnement la sortie d'hôpital au
g prado qui a d'abord concerné maternité
nous voulons monter en charge très
rapidement sur le programme prado dans
les 18 mois qui viennent pour que au
moins un tiers des patients insuffisants
cardiaques il sort de l'hôpital soit
accompagnée c'est à dire que nous
faisons le lien entre l'hôpital la ville
les prochaines de santé de ville pour
assurer une prise en charge trop de
patients qui sortent de l'hôpital
insuffisants cardiaques ne voient pas
accorder leur généraliste dans les
quinze jours dans le mois qui suit dans
l'hospitalisation troisième sujet j'y
reviendrai peut-être sur l'organisation
territoriale créer des équipes de soins
spécialisés notamment en cardiologie on
a des acteurs motivés pour le faire on
s'éteint attentes à la fois des patients
et aussi des médecins généralistes
d'avoir un point de contact des équipes
de soins spécialisés qui permet
d'adresser les patients et qui permet
aussi structurelles sur le territoire
une prise en charge de la
télésurveillance des consultations
avancées g reviendra également sur
l'organisation des soins territoriales
et puis dernier élément aussi développer
la télésurveillance à l'ensemble des
patients qui présentent une insuffisance
cardiaque sévère il ya des choses qui
ont été faites dans le cadre de
l'article 51 et que nous voulons
maintenant généralisé sur la base y
compris la loi de financement de la r si
je là encore pardon madame la présidente
je fais très vite mais
difficile de résumer le rapport en
quelques minutes le nous avons donc mené
un travail important sur la situation de
sanitaires d'aider des femmes ans était
sûr maternité et de la petite enfance
qui ont montré à la fois
certain nombre de constats qui était
plus ou moins bien connu un gradient
social important en termes d'exposition
à des à des risques sur le tabac sur
l'alcool au matière de maternité un
suivi des enfants qui est encore trop
hétérogène trop de consommation de
médicaments par rapport à d'autres pays
pour les 0 6 ans des examens
obligatoires qui sont insuffisamment
réaliser ou insuffisamment suivi est qui
et qui justifient de notre côté trois
séries de propositions au moins je m'en
tiens aux plus importantes améliorer
l'accompagnement des femmes pendant la
grossesse et après l'accouchement
ça veut dire quoi notamment ça veut dire
trois choses
encourager les femmes à choisir une
sage-femme référence nous finalisons une
négociation avec des sages femmes sur ce
sujet là et publie à venir là des
passions du syndrome post partum c'est
tout le programme mille premiers jours
que nous déployons avec un nouvel
entretien post natale et nous proposons
que les sages-femmes à l'image des
médecins peut-être que ça n'était prévu
par la loi de financement des dernières
puissent prescrire des des soins de
psychothérapie de psychologues avec le
dispostif mon psy qui a été ouvert aux
médecins mais tu as encore aux
sages-femmes deuxième proposition
systématiser le repérage à l'école des
troubles du langage
et j'ai des troubles visuels pour tous
les enfants de trois ans nous avons
engagées depuis maintenant deux ans des
expérimentations avec les orthophonistes
les orthoptistes et l'éducation
nationale pour organiser la formation
des professionnels à l'éducation
nationale et leur permettre d'adresser
aux orthophonistes orthoptistes des
enfants dont ils identifient les risques
de troubles visuels du langage et du
langage et nous voulons de systématiser
cette expérimentation sur l'ensemble des
territoires dans l'est dans les deux ans
qui viennent parce que ça marche parce
que ça permet une meilleure qualité
d'adressage par des professionnels de
santé de ville et une identification
plus rapide de ces précoce de ces
troubles troisième proposition
faire de mon espace santé le vrai carnet
de santé numérique de l'enfant on a
lancé vous le savez depuis le mois de
février mon espace santé on a maintenant
la quasi totalité de la population
française qui a un espace de santé
ouverte puisque très peu d'assurés
sociaux opposés à cette création donc
soit ils ont activé soit par le
mécanisme de l'opt out il a été activé
au bout d'un peu plus de six semaines or
cet espace santé potentiellement il peut
il doit devenir le vrai carnet de santé
numérique de l'enfant pour permettre aux
parents d'avoir un carnet de santé
facilement accessible aux vielles de
santé de le remplir de façon
dématérialisée et puis de nous permettre
sans doute de d'améliorer le suivi à la
fin des examens à réaliser et puis de
suivi épidémiologique
des enfants et deux monnaies les actions
correctrices qui seront issues de ce
suivi amélioré
si je continue ce survol un peu rapide
dans les différentes analyses que nous
avons réalisés on a fait deux analyses
sectorielles comme on le fait chaque
année une sur la biologie médicale et
l'autre sur l'accès aux médicaments
innovants sur la biologie médicale le
rapport met en avant
si je suis là aussi un peu synthétique
la très forte concentration du secteur
de la biologie médicale depuis dix ans
aujourd'hui près de six groupes
représentent plus de 60 % de la dépense
du biologique médicale et cette
concentration d'une part d'ailleurs on
peut le s'en féliciter c'est accompagné
d'un maintien de la de la densité du
nombre de sites de laboratoires de
biologie médicale y en avait quatre
mille 60 en 2009 y en à 4160 en 2021
donc on est sur des chiffres très
satisfaisants en termes d'accès aux
soins et cette concentration s'est
accompagnée surtout d'une augmentation
significative de la rentabilité du
secteur puisque même avant la caisse que
vides la biologie médicale en france
mais on voit dans d'autres pays
européens
est un secteur économique très rentable
puisque présente un ratio excédent brut
d'exploitation par rapport au chiffre
d'affaires de l'ordre de 10 9% ce qui
est assez significatif par rapport à
d'autres secteurs économiques et que
évidemment la crise qu vida à la fois
fortement augmenté chiffre d'affaires
d'un moratoire de biologie et contribuer
à encore augmenter leur rentabilité
puisqu'elle était en 2020 dont qu avec
seulement une année de crise si j'ose
dire à monter à 23% et qu'il est
probable que ce niveau de rentabilité
soit confirmée en 2021 voir en 2022
malgré les baisses de prix des tests pcr
que l'assurance maladie a réalisé de
publi mai 2000 2020 nous proposons de ce
point de vue là de changer le pilotage
financier du secteur à la fois de faire
de la convention avec le biologiste
médical une vraie convention hausse en
ce sens assurance maladie du terme avec
de la maîtrise médicalisée des dépenses
des missions que nous santé publique
confiée aux biologistes et aussi une
évolution du pilotage tarifaire qui
passe à la fois par des enveloppes
dédiées à l'innovation on a des
innovations en matière de biologie qui
doivent passer du secteur hospitalier au
secteur de l'huile il faut des
enveloppes pour ça et aussi des
ajustements tarifaires nous proposons de
baisser les tarifs de la biologie dans
les prochaines années et dès 2023 pour
un montant en 2023 280 millions d'euros
mais se sait baisse devrait se
poursuivre dans les années à venir 2e
une thématique du rapport sur l'accès
aux médicaments innovants là encore très
rapidement nous avons vu depuis
plusieurs années pas mal d'études qui
pourraient montrer une forme de retard
de la france dans l'accès aux
médicaments innovants en comparant les
performances du système français à nos
voisins européens or il nous est apparu
que ce c'est très bonne analyse était en
réalité un parfait puisque ne prenait
pas en compte le des dispositifs d'accès
précoce et notamment les dispositifs
date ait eu qui permettent en france
pour beaucoup d'assurés beaucoup
traitement un accès rapide à des
médicaments innovants et donc nous avons
lancé une étude en coopération avec 4,3
pays européens voisins l'allemagne
l'italie et l'espagne pour pouvoir faire
une étude sur 12 médicaments innovants
notamment des anti cancéreux mais pas
seulement et de voir effectivement quels
étaient les chiffres et dès lors qu'on
intègre des dispositifs d'accès précoce
on voit que les performances du système
français sont bien meilleurs que les
études qui peuvent circuler on est
notamment sur cette comparaison des 4
pays un peu moins bons plans le
mannequin système
particulier de négociation après
voilà exactement et mais on est bien
meilleur que les italiens si j'ose dire
est que les espagnols le sujet n'est pas
de se dire si on est meilleur que
l'espagnol mais deux d'avoir un système
c'est notre proposition d'observation
qui prend en compte justement l'ensemble
dispositif d'accès précoce qui soit
partagée avec l'ensemble des pays
européens c'est notre proposition sur
cette thématique
quatrième fil rouge qui sans doute un
des plus importants je crois du rapport
sur l'accès aux soins et qui rejoint
d'ailleurs peut-être des questions peut
que vous évoquez dans le dans
l'opposition
deux thématiques d'une taxe et financier
aux soins notre bac c'est territoriale
accès financier le rapport fait un point
détaillé sur le 100 % santé
et et montre je crois des résultats très
satisfaisants sur notamment sur le
dentaire est sûre l'audioprothèse avec
des taux de pénétration des paniers 100%
santé très significatif et une
augmentation du recours aux soins pour
ces deux champs très important un bilan
plus nuancé sur le l'optique
même s'ils
ne faut pas négliger
l'intérêt du dispositif 100% santé
notamment pour les pays tiers la c2 est
ce qui leur a permis d'accéder à la fois
une diversité d'offres et une qualité
d'offres meilleur qu'il s'agisse des
montures ou des verts et en rappelant
que l'assurance maladie a engagé sur
l'optique à la fin de campagne
d'accompagnement des opticiens puisque
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de plus
de dix mille magasins d'optique à
l'automne 2021 pour leur rappeler les
règles du jeu et du surpoids santé et
que nous avons engagées depuis début
d'année une campagne de contrôles pour
le coût de près de 200 magasins
d'optique qui aboutissent à une centaine
de procédures de sanction ou de
pénalités financières qui sont en cours
pour non respect du cahier des charges
100% sorte et notamment de la
présentation des devis et de
l'information en magasin des assurés
toujours est il que nous proposons de
d'élargir cette démarche à d'autres
champs de l'offre de soins pas forcément
stricte stricto sensu du sens pour 60 et
parce que les conditions sont pas
forcément réunies mais de travailler sur
des mécanismes permettant de diminuer le
reste à charge des patients et on nous
propose de l'homme d'instruire ces
sujets dans 3 2 un son de porter et de
différentes d'une part les prothèses
capillaires pour dire les choses plus
clairement les financements de perruques
pour les pour les femmes post punk
chimiothérapie sur lequel nous notons
des restes à charges élevées du fait de
classification des différentes prothèses
capillaires avec des tarifs parfois
élevés et donc nous proposons là pour le
coup ça pourrait s'inscrire assez
largement dans un dispositif 100 % pur
sang santé classique c'est-à-dire
financement et ouais mais c'est sur un
panier avec un prix limite de vente
permettant de faire du haut 0 reste à
charge deuxième sujet des semelles
orthopédiques
sujet un peu spécifique mais qui peut
être important sur lequel on a encore un
travail important sur la nomenclature de
ces de ces dispositifs médicaux à opérer
et puis sujet qui et je dirai en
personne concernée en ayant dépensé plus
important suffisait de l'orthodontie sur
lequel nous notons des restes à charges
élevées pour les notamment pour les
familles pour leurs enfants les jeunes
et des adolescents et avec des taux de
dépassement qui sont extrêmement
dynamiques et de façon quasiment
mécanique puisque depuis le puits
notamment 2013 les taux de dépassement
progresse de 3 et demi pour cent par an
et était de 217 % en 2013 et sont
maintenant 2 244% en 2021 avec vous
savez certainement des tarifs parfois
élevés dans certains départements
éventuellement de la région parisienne
où de grandes métropoles et donc
typiquement sur ce sujet là il serait
sans doute déraisonnable de vouloir
faire un 100 % santé entre guillemets
classique
puisque les à la fois cela exposerait
les dépenses d'aidé complémentaire à des
dépenses très élevées et puis ça sera
pas forcément extrêmement pertinent mais
il nous semble utile de réfléchir avec
les acteurs chirurgien dentiste
orthodontiste et assureurs
complémentaires à une façon de réguler
au mieux les tarifs du secteur ce qu'il
faut mettre un prix limite de vente sur
pour essayer de mettre le holà sur des
tarifs élevés est-ce qu'il faut mieux
différencier des choses qui relève de
l'esthétique du soin ce qui est un peu
compliqué et voilà comment on construit
ça pour encore une fois diminuer les
restes à charge des familles deuxième
volet de ceux de ce paquet si j'ose dire
accès aux soins c'est d'accepter rites
orientaux soins qu'il a aussi rejoint je
pense à certains de vos préoccupations
on a souhaité faire trois séries de
propositions
autour de l'axé d'un meilleur accès
territoriale de soins la première
proposition elle et elle tourne autour
de l'idée de fournir aux médecins
traitants ou en relation des acteurs une
vraie boîte à outils pour garantir un
meilleur accès justement à un médecin
traitant dans le contexte de diminution
de la densité
de médecins généralistes ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire essayer de construire
autour des médecins traitants une vraie
équipe de soins un assistant médical une
infirmière éventuellement une ip à une
affaire meraz allait
alléger la charge administrative des
médecins déployer des protocoles de
coopération promouvoir les délégations
de tâches mais autour d'une logique de
construire une équipe de soins autour
des médecins
nous pensons possible au vu des premiers
résultats des assistants médicaux qui
sont prometteurs avec des augmentations
de file active et de patientèle médecin
traitant entre 5 à 10 % de faire gagner
aux médecins traitants un temps
extrêmement précieux en termes de prise
en charge de leur permettre non pas de
travailler plus mais de travailler je
dirais mieux est de leur permettre de
prendre en charge davantage de patients
avec une équipe de soins autour de ça
c'est la première proposition la
deuxième composition autour de
inégalités de santé vise à organiser la
présence de médecins spécialistes
libéraux en zones sous denses avec des
consultations avancées
régulière en dehors de leur cabinet
dans des endroits au soudan ce pour dire
les choses plus clairement faire que un
médecin spécialiste fasse une à deux
demi journées tous les tous les quinze
jours dans des zones dans les communes
dotées de peu de médecins spécialistes
en complément de son activité par
exemple dans les dents dans des
métropoles dans des villes de taille
plus grands ça c'est le premier point ça
nous semble à la fois souhaitable et
possible pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins spécialisés
sera sans doute un des sujets la
négociation conventionnelle que nous
aurons et puis le deuxième sujet c'est
de simplifier et de rendre sans doute
plus lisibles les contrats d' aides à
l'installation en zones sous denses avec
si possible un contrat unique
d'installations dans ces zones là même
si nous l'avons montré ce sujet des
menées sans doute pas le seul sujet pour
permettre de faire face aux enjeux de la
démographie médicale et de la
répartition sur le territoire troisième
sujet troisième proposition autour de la
téléconsultation 7 téléconsultation elle
c'est à la fois installé dans le paysage
de l'organisation des soins mais elle
est méritée pour nous un cadre plus plus
structurel puisque on voit des pratiques
ce cher qui sont pas complètement
satisfaisante et donc on propose
notamment d'avancé sur quatre idées
développées et même si aujourd'hui les
tarifs qui existe déjà mais mieux faire
connaître la possibilité de faire des
téléconsultations assisté notamment à
domicile pour permettre notamment un
infirmier d'aller d'aller au domicile
des patients de faire une télé
consultation avec un médecin traitant
dans son cabinet on voit bien que les
médecins traitants de toute façon dans
les prochaines années quelles que soient
les valorisations tarifaire qu'on peut
faire on peut de temps pour se déplacer
davantage à domicile donc l'idée d'avoir
plutôt ce binôme infirmiers médecins
avec de la téléconsultation assister il
nous semble qu'il faut mieux faire
connaître le dispositif qui encore une
fois bénéfices donne d'ores et déjà de
tarifs dédié deuxième sujet c'est de
donner un de créer un vrai statut
haddock d'offrir de télémédecine
aujourd'hui vous le savez les à la fois
les plateformes ceux de télémédecine se
développent et des télécabines également
tout ça mérite pour nous et c'est un
constat une proposition assez largement
partagée avec les équipes du ministère
de la santé un vrai statut plus clair
plus transparent
davantage gage de qualité également
parce qu'on voit des pratiques qui sont
un tout petit peu on va dire ça comme ça
condamnable et donc il est sans doute
nécessaire après cette phase un peu
particulière de décollage de la
téléconsultation dans la période que vit
de donner un vrai statut et avec des
obligations également
deux qualités et d'organisation sur ses
plate forme de télémédecine et une
troisième proposition nous nous
proposons de supprimer la prise en
charge des arrêts de travail qui sont
prescrits en téléconsultation quand ce
n'est pas le médecin traitant nous
voyons des des rides significative de
fait que d'assurer qu'ils font une deux
trois quatre cinq téléconsultation avant
d'obtenir un arrêt de travail et il nous
semble que il est tout de même
préférable si ce n'est pas votre médecin
traitant qui vous connaît que un arrêt
de travail soit prescrit par un échange
physique une présence physique d'un
patient dans le cabinet d'un médecin et
non pas en quelques clics si vous me
permettez l'expression sur une
plateforme de téléconsultation
aujourd'hui en 2021 on a eu près de
200000 téléconsultation prescrit
aboutissant à une prescription d'arrêt
travail sans que ce soit le médecin
traitant qu'ils en soient à l'origine
pour un montant de 95 millions d'euros
et il est probable que ce volume mais ce
montant est à vocation à augmenter très
significativement si nous mettons pas
des garde-fous nécessaires
dernière proposition c'est d'accélérer
de soutenir le développement des
organisations territoriales de
téléconsultation un certain nombre
notamment de ses pts sont inscrits dans
cette démarche là et ça nous semblait un
bon je dirais un bon mix entre eux
accéder à une télé consultation et en
même temps permettre de maintenir un
lien avec le territoire dernière
proposition sur ce bloc la présidente
mais je serai rapide puisque son nez
dans l'activité je crois qu'on aimera
ces deux évidemment participé à la mise
en oeuvre des mesures d'urgence sur les
soins non programmés et 2 comment dirais
je veux participer à leur évaluation
puisque à l'est sud est et on aura
évidemment à mesurer ce qui aura marché
le cas échéant sera éventuellement
marché et d'en tirer des enseignements
de manière je termine ce survol rapide
mais peut-être un peu trop long 2 du
rapport charié produit par le dernier
chapitre qui n'est pas le moins
important autour de l'efficience et de
la pertinence des soins du paquet
d'économies si j'ose dire d'abord pour
vous dire qu'on a souhaité situer ce
travail résolument dans un cadre
pluriannuel on parle beaucoup de l'ondam
plus rien elle en a souhaité mieux mieux
différencier dans notre dans notre dans
nos propositions d'économies les
économies je dirais de court terme qui
sont liées notamment à des opérations de
maîtrise médicalisée de contrôle qui ont
un rendement immédiat en 2023 d'actions
de plus long terme qui peuvent avoir un
impact économique faible à très court
terme et qui vont monter en puissance
dans les années à venir et de le faire
en lien avec nos fils rouges et donc on
a construit un tableau d'économies avec
des économies liées à l' approche par
pathologie par la proche parent
population et puis ensuite une
description plus classique en
d'économies en matière d'efficience de
pertinence de contrôle et de lutte
contre la fraude donc tous à aboutir à
un montant de 1,2 milliard d'euros
160 millions d'euros autour d'actions
structurelles pathologie parcours de
soins prévention 7h50 millions d'euros
autour des actions déficient cette
pertinence et 300 millions d'euros
autour des actions de contrôle et de
lutte contre la fraude donc avec une
augmentation significative nos objectifs
de lutte contre la fraude de près de 25%
je ne vais pas rentrer dans le détail
sur chacun des items pour dire qu'on
sera voilà on a identifié des sujets
prioritaires d'action survient sur les
produits de santé avec des médicaments
biosimilaires tech bio 6000 et être
biosimilaires pardon prévention de
l'antibiorésistance
renforcement de notre plan d'action
général sur les années de travail
relance des travaux sur la pertinence en
matière d'imagerie médicale et puis je
les dis renforcement de la ville offre
notamment des facturations
inadéquate des professionnels de santé
dans la continuité des travaux que j'ai
pu présenter auprès de la commission il
ya quelques semaines sur l'évaluation de
la fraude notamment du côté des
infirmiers libéraux
ce rapide survol des propositions
charges et produits pour 2023 merci
monsieur le directeur en effet c'est un
rapport très dense mais avec beaucoup de
propositions et
pour ma part certaines rejoignent des
propositions que l'on a fait lors des
différentes
commissions d enquête ou mission
d'information que l'on n'a pu faire je
vais tout de suite passé la parole à
corinne imbert rapporteur pour la
branche maladie est ensuite jean sol
aussi aura des questions à poser
merci la présente merci monsieur le
directeur pour votre présentation et
merci pour la synthèse du rapport voilà
j'ai beaucoup apprécié et tous ceux très
prix et cette synthèse était facile à
lire donc merci infiniment à vous et à
vos services
on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet pas
mal de questions à vous poser pardonnez
moi tout d'abord sur le déficit il site
historique troisième déficit historique
vous l'avez rappelé qui serait de 20
milliards d'euros pour 2022
et vous le dit dans le rapport la
branche maladie confrontés à des visites
inédites et durable alors est-ce qu'on
peut envisager un jour un retour pérenne
à l' équilibre financier ou pas leur on
y était presque à un moment donné et
puis il ya eu la crise et puis
l'augmentation de la csg le mouvement
des gilet jaune les les mesures prises
et puis ça
engendré un déficit pour la sécurité
sociale et puis là on a un projet ne
doit pouvoir d'achat qui va aussi privé
lacie coat et social un certain manque
de recettes donc bon voilà est-ce que
vous avez une vision ou pas ou est ce
qu'il faut qu'on accepte à un moment
donné que la sécurité sociale soit
toujours en déficit
les mesures pour l'été vous vous lavez
un peu abordée à la fin est ce que vous
pouvez nous nous chiffré le coût des
différentes mesures parce que vous
n'avez pas parlé beaucoup de chiffres ce
matin un petit peu alors je sais bien
fallait pas nous a sauvés peut-être avec
des chiffres mais bon c'est quand même
important parle de chargés de produits
donc sur ces mesures prises par le
ministre de la santé de la prévention ce
que vous pouvez est-ce que vous avez
chiffré le coût des mesures
concernant la la la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux
vous avez évoqué le panorama des
professionnels de santé de ville vous
avez évoqué un meilleur accès
territoriales aux soins construit autour
du médecin traitant donc d'abord
fragments d un médecin traitant - un
certain nombre de patients aujourd'hui
qu'il n'en manque pas mais ils ont parlé
autour du médecin de ville mais
quelle marge de manoeuvre à la cnam sur
ces sujets là quel est ce que vous avez
un est ce que vous imaginez des
dispositions dont vous nous auriez pas
parler est ce que vous envisagez par
exemple est ce que vous envisagez de
créer des centres de santé
avec des médecins salariés au niveau de
l'assurance maladie
quelle marge de manoeuvre vous avez au
niveau de la tête
je passe à l'hôpital
j'ai pas vu beaucoup de propositions sur
l'hôpital mais je n'ai peut-être pas
assez vu où
j'ai peut-être sauter une page comme le
dit mon voisin vous aviez évoqué devant
la commission d' enquête sur l'hôpital
l'évolution de la nomenclature des actes
hospitaliers
où on en est de la rationalisation de la
nomenclature mais aussi la
revalorisation de certains actes
largement vous aviez évoqué devant la
commission en fin d'année dernière
l'objectif de rendre les nomenclatures
plus souple et adaptatives afin de mieux
intégrer des innovations thérapeutiques
est ce qu'il ya eu des avancées dans ce
domaine
quels financements alors je reviens sur
l'hôpital toujours mais comment le
concernant le financement quelle
évolution seront envisagées et qu'elle
prévisibilité sur la trajectoire des
ressources et l'évolution des tarifs
alors peut-être pas vous qui en charge
de fixer l'ondam sûr que vous avez
vous avez peut-être aussi une vision là
dessus peut-être que c'est pas de votre
ressort donc vôtre est peut-être en
touche le joker mais comment vous voyez
les choses
qu'en est il ou pour faire simple d'une
expérimentation l'expérimentation d'un
nouveau mode de financement de l'hôpital
sur la question de la santé mère-enfant
vous en fait une priorité d'action vin
parmi les les actions vous voulez là
vous mettez en avant comment vous allez
vous coordonnée avec les services de
protection maternelle et infantile des
conseils départementaux
puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est une compétence
des conseils départementaux
concernant 100% sentez vous nous en
avait fait un rapide retour
donc avec les propositions de d'élargir
un dans trois domaines que nous avait
présenté les pour faire simple et
perruques et semelles orthopédiques de
l'orthodontie
est ce que vous pensez être suivi sur ce
sur ces points-là par le gouvernement
j'entends bien que ce sont des
propositions mais là aussi vous avez
droit à un joker et
éventuellement est ce que vous l'avez
chiffres et vous avez dit que si c'était
à 100% santé ça coûterait ça coûterait
beaucoup d'argent voilà comment ça peut
qu'elle a qu'elle qui vous voulez vous
l'évaluez
concernant la grande sait qu est ce que
la caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
a des projets de redéfinition de ses
missions d'évolution de ces prises en
charge vous êtes déjà une grande sécu
pour certains assurés avec la
complémentaire santé solidaire et quel
bilan la questure tel de cette gestion
d'une complémentaire
enfin
parce que ça avait fait l'objet d'un
amendement par l'assemblée nationale
l'année dernière dans le projet d'oise
c'est que tu es social que nous avions
supprimer parce que nous étions hors
champ
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale le contrôle des centres
des centres dentaires
est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus est-ce que les dérives
importantes pointé ont été objective et
et pour vous riez pourriez vous en
fournir le nombre de contrôle d'ores et
déjà engagé en 2022 et les suites
réservées aux anomalies constatées voilà
je vous remercie et pardon d'avoir été
un peu longue avec toutes mes questions
question donc je vous propose de
répondre directement madame rapporteur
suite merci des amériques main après
demain la important je vais essayer de
pas trop puisé de joker
beaucoup de médicaments beaucoup de
sujets sur les perspectives financières
évidemment vous vous avez rappelé
l'historique vous le connaissez on est
nous étions tout proches de le
déséquilibre de l'assurance maladie en
2009 en 2019 et dans les premiers mois
de 2009 1 après une décennie de eu de
maîtrise des dépenses et de
l'affectation de recettes à l'assurance
maladie qui a permis aux dressement
après la crise financière de 2008 2009
et nous sommes évidemment quelques mois
hors parti sur des déficits historiques
à la fois se dire tout de même que c'est
difficile de son temps en réduction
rapide puisqu'on est passé 30 milliards
d'euros à moins de 20 milliards
perspectives en 2022 mais évidemment
constitue un défi pour la stabilité de
l'assurance maladie
pour répondre clairement à votre
question je ne pense pas que le maintien
durable de déficit à ces niveaux-là de
l'assurance maladie est soutenable pour
des raisons que vous évidemment mesure
est parfaitement que chaque chaque année
de déficit constitue une augmentation de
la dette et que même si une partie des
déficits entre guillemets que vie des
quelque part entre guillemets d'ores et
déjà financées par l'allongement de la
durée de vie de la cades est ce alors
ils ont 2033
il est bien évident que cet allongement
ne couvre par les déficits cumulés que
nous allons connaître dans les années à
venir donc ce qui est pour nous justifie
d'abord fondamentalement en tant que la
situation dans ce mail a dit un
engagement déterminé dans des programmes
d'action en matière de déficiences et
pertinence des soins on peut se dire que
1 milliard de mesures alors pour 2023
ces faibles par rapport à un déficit
proche de 20 milliards d'euros en même
temps j'aurais envie de vous dire que si
nous arrivons d'ores et déjà à réaliser
l'ensemble de ces mesures là ont fait
oeuvre utile et qu' aucune de ces
mesures n'est complètement facile à
mettre en oeuvre
à court ou à moyen terme et que je ne
crois pas évidemment dans le contexte
actuel a l'opportunité
d'un plan massif de l'économie en
matière de santé je crois que ce serait
évidemment totalement hors de propos
deuxième élément de réponse mais là qui
dépasse assez largement ma condition
il est clair que le pilotage des
dépenses des finances et des kills de
l'assurance-maladie s'inscrit dans un
cadre plus général des finances ce
social d'abord des finances publiques au
sens large et que je pense que le
gouvernement aura dans les prochaines
semaines à la fois au travers du
programme de stabilité qui bientôt
amassé 1 à bruxelles et bien évidemment
des présentations des projets loi de
finances et de financement à la rentrée
l'occasion de préciser la programmation
des finances publiques pour les
prochaines années la sécurité sociale à
sion s'est pas uni connaît un déficit
élevé les retraites également et ça va
se continuer dans les prochaines années
d'autres branches parce qu'elles
connaissent une situation plus favorable
et donc sans doute aussi dans un cadre
plus général des finances sociales et
des finances publiques que la réponse se
trouve mais encore une fois notre
mission à nous ces deux garantir que
dans ce contexte de déficits élevés
comme on nous dit de façon peut-être un
peu galvaudé mais ça vaut la peine d'y
revenir chaque euro dépensé côté
assurance m'a dit d'y aller de façon
efficace et nous savons le rapport le
montre encore cette année que nous avons
des des zones et des chants et des dévié
pour lutter contre 7,7 inefficiences
s'agissant des mesures d'urgence je suis
un tout petit peu gêné pour vous
répondre sur une évaluation des coûts
etc santé parce que
[Musique]
c'est tout ça est évidemment extrêmement
dépendant notamment des conditions dans
lesquelles les acteurs vont se saisir de
différents dispositifs que ce soit de
l'amélioration de la rémunération de la
régulation que ce soit des 15 euros par
un médecin
effecteur du de des soins non programmés
ou d'autres dispositifs de ce genre et
que par ailleurs c'est le ministère de
la santé qui consolide l'ensemble de ces
chiffres je prends simplement un exemple
pour illustrer que peut-être les débris
sont pas des plus importantes ne sont
pas forcément là où on les attend un des
principaux postes en réalité de dépenses
pour l'assurance maladie c'est le
maintien
dans les trois mois qui viennent de la
téléconsultation prise en charge à 100%
puisque si on se dit que
si on se dit qu'on a à peu près un
million de téléconsultation par mois
grosso modo
le maintien la prise en charge du ticket
modérateur par l'assurance maladie sur
la période ça représentera une dépense
de 18 millions d'euros voilà donc après
il ya des dépenses aussi côté hôpital
que nous ne nous ne mesurons pas à mon
liées aux mesures sur la nuit qui ont
été décidée aux tirs sur cette période
mais voilà en tout cas nous ne nous
faisons pas de chiffrage de santé nous
mesurons bien sûr très précisément
l'activité conseiller de concernés par
les parlers soutenue par les mesures qui
ont été très et et nous ferons nous
participerons évidemment sous l'autorité
du ministre à ce suivi régulier et à ce
bilan est que ces ex post mais excentré
ne dispose pas d'éléments ou consolider
vous perdrez part de greffons de manière
complètement satisfaisante
s'agissant de des mesures d'accès au
soir
alors entre dans le champ qui essuient
la science m'a dit nous considérons
qu'on a qu'on a beaucoup de le lier à
activer et que
même si on peut avoir le sentiment
quelque part une forme d'impuissance par
rapport aux déserts médicaux par rapport
à l'accès aux soins ce n'est pas du tout
notre foi notre philosophie notre
perception et je vous donne simplement
un exemple chiffré pour le groupe qui
permet d'illustrer cela aujourd'hui en
france un médecin traitant prend en
charge en tant que médecin traitant un
peu plus de mille patients
alors et pourtant il travaille beaucoup
les médecins généralistes travaillent
plus 50 heures plus de 45 heures devant
les patients
et pourtant quand on regarde les autres
pays européens il traîne peu tout seul -
moins de patients chat parce que
justement ils n'ont pas d'équipé autour
d'eux un calcul purement théorique
j'insiste bien sur le purement théorique
montre que si nous voulons que chaque
français et un médecin traitant dans les
prochaines années il faut que cette
patientèle moyenne monte à 1200 mhz et
1200 vins très précis ça n'est pas hors
de portée et ça n'est pas hors de portée
et quand on voit simplement entre
guillemets le fait de ce que produit une
assistance médicale auprès des médecins
traitants qui l'ont choisi on voit que
cette augmentation de patientèle elle
est possible et donc je sais pour ça que
je dis que y'en a pas d'impulsions c'est
que en réalité les leviers il existe il
existait gagner du temps médical en
mettant auprès des médecins des
professionnels assistant médical un
fermier notamment
permettant à cette équipe de prendre en
charge plus de passion ça veut dire sans
doute que
si le médecin par exemple
on dire je travaille à l'unique unité à
soi en libéral j'y reviendrai juste
après 100 salariés peut-être qu'un
certain nombre de ces patients est bien
seront vus parfois par l'ipea parfois
par lui en direct mais ce qui est
certain c'est que il ploie avec son
équipe prendre en charge plus de
bastions donc vous me tiens par contre
de faire des questions et des réponses
mais qu'est ce qui se passe là où il n'y
a pas de médecin traitant nous pensons
que la structuration de ses équipes de
soins autour des médecins traitants peut
à la fois consolider l'offre sur les
zones territoriales fragile ramener
potentiellement des médecins là où ils
vont pas s'installer tout seul parce
qu'ils ont peur de faire face à une
activité déraisonnable et derrière ça il
ya la structuration de ces pts
association d'appui à ces cabinets
généralistes la simplification des
tâches administratives l'amélioration
des outils numériques la place de la
téléconsultation est donc un ensemble de
levier
l'envoi de médecins spécialistes en
zones sous denses qui permet d'être le
relais du meta temps pourquoi mais
tintin on va pas s'installer dans un
département que je connais bien autour
de cherbourg à valognes où un
parce qu'il n'y a pas de menace et les
spécialistes si demain il sait que
autres de lui il a des demi journées de
consultations avancées se font de
dermato de gynéco de cardio alors on lui
donne les conditions pour que et puis
rester s'installer avec là aussi une
équipe de soins en ayant en tête je
pense que là aussi le rapport est utile
je pense que quelque part nous ne
mesurons pas assez collectivement
l'impact des changements démographiques
d'évolution de santé qui sont arrivées
d'un temps qui vont venir dans les dix
ans qui viennent en 20 ans nous avons
doublé doublé le nombre d'infirmiers
libéraux de ce pays on avait cinquante
mille infirmiers libéraux en 2000 on en
a cent mille aujourd'hui semble donc on
a augmenté coût plus vite que la
population protégée beaucoup plus vite
que le vieillissement de la population
beaucoup lui que le nombre d'années dé
c'est une bonne nouvelle à nous
d'utiliser entre guillemets de faire et
dans les dix ans qui viennent alors
modulo évidemment ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui de
évidemment de pas de grandes émissions
mais en tout cas de ce défi
d'attractivité des professions de santé
mais dans les dix ans qui viennent et
les projections d'adressent de l'om dps
du hk montre qu' on aura trente à
cinquante mille infirmiers libéraux de
plus dans notre pays à l'horizon 2030
c'est considérable et donc nous pouvons
construire auprès des médecins ce qui
fait d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays cet
apport au sein des équipes de soins mais
qui doit se faire dans un double
mouvement des équipes de soins
qu'attends tu es aussi c'est vrai
davantage de délégations de tâches sans
doute dans le mouvement qu'on a déjà
connu mais de façon organisée en en
tirant les enseignements en termes de
modèle économique c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes en train de
finaliser avec les syndicats
d'infirmiers libéraux une négociation
sur les i p à on a un modèle économique
sur les épées à aujourd'hui en libéral
qui ne fonctionne pas bien on veut mieux
le valoriser augmenter les forfaits de
suzy leur permettre de suivre des
patients ponctuelles en lien avec les
médecins traitants augmenter leur file
active leur donner les moyens d'avoir
été une activité dans la durée pérenne
en lien avec les médecins traitants et
sur un modèle économique plus plus
stable donc voilà en tout cas nous
pensons que nous pouvons alors après
évidemment il ya des leviers qui ne sont
pas dans notre main il avant dans la
main du législateur et de gouvernement
sur d'autres types de mesures je me
situe à ce stade dans un champ
conventionnel
conforme à ce qui existe aujourd'hui
vous m'avez interrogé sur la sur la
nomenclature et la réforme de la
nomenclature ce que je peux simplement
vous dire c'est que le le conseil pour
la nomenclature la nomenclature est
maintenant totalement installé et est au
travail
avec près d'une quarantaine de
comités par famille dac commencé à
travailler par robert spécialité mais
pas exactement par spécialité pour
pouvoir voilà construire cette nouvelle
réalisation d'ici normalement la rentrée
ils auront établi une première liste des
acteurs opèrent de la nomenclature qui
permettra ensuite de travail et famille
par famille et qui permettra de répondre
aux
objectifs que j'avais évoqué un méfait
devant vous il ya quelques mois et que
vous avez appelé d'une réforme en tant
que tel de la hiérarchisation de la
structuration actuelle de la
nomenclature et aussi d'une condition
d'une d'une vie de cette nomenclature
qui soit plus
souple que tous les quinze ans une bande
d'une grande remise à jour c'est un
travail extrêmement lourd complexe qui
sera aussi techniquement et
financièrement sans doute complexe
puisque les enjeux de nouvelles et
hiérarchisation montrait qu'il ya des
actifs finalement aujourd'hui
coûte beaucoup moins cher à réaliser que
d'autres dans l'autre sens des actes
innovant qu'il faudra prendre en charge
qui coûteront potentiellement chers aux
plus chers et donc cet équilibre là il
faudra aussi le construire dans la
discussion avec nos partenaires
conventionnels mais tout le monde l'a
bien en tête sur les réformes du
financement l'hôpital alors
s'en vouloir
du coup sortir le joker simplement vous
le savez rappelé qu' évidemment la
science mais il n'est pas né pas je
dirais en première ligne sur ces sujets
et c'est avant tout nos amis du
ministère de la santé qui pilote ces
réformes du financement vous savez que
c'est déjà implémenté la réforme du côté
de la deûle à psychiatrique est prévu
pour 2023 l'a rendue nécessaire
nous travaillons de notre côté a dans le
cadre de l'article 51 à différentes
expérimentations qui font bouger les
règles du jeu du financement dans
l'hôpital je pense notamment aux travaux
sur les épisodes de soins avec notamment
le qui avance sur le d'expérimentation
de financement à l'épisode de soins sur
certains types de prise en charge
prothèse de hanche programmé prothèse de
genou notamment on pourra y revenir si
vous le souhaitez mais ces sujets-là
chemine et puis dans le rapport nous
serait révoquée mais nous proposons
notamment de renforcer la place de la du
financement la qualité ou dans le
financement hospitalier comme celui des
soins de ville avoir les mêmes
indicateurs pour les dispositifs de
financement la qualité en ville et à
l'hôpital
expérimenté des logiques de best
practice qui permet de mieux valoriser
le financement la qualité au travers du
regard et d'indicateurs est donc un
certain nombre d'éléments qui pourraient
permettre de contribuer à
enrichir le financement à l'hôpital
s'agissant de
la prise en charge des enfants et des
familles sur la pmi nous nous
nous souhaitons pas de nouvelle formule
est comme ça fortement essayé de
resserrer les liens avec la avec les
équipes des pmi et voir les conditions
dans lesquelles nous pouvons accompagner
cette activité de prise en charge que ce
soit sur les modalités juridiques de
systèmes d'information voire voir
financiers voilà c'est des choses qu'on
veut ré engagé avec avec ces équipes là
parce que nous nous pensons qu'un
renforcement de la coordination entre
entre les équipes de la pmi des soins de
ville notamment est de nature à
améliorer la coordination et la qualité
de la prise en charge pour les enfants
sur le 100 % santé je veux évidemment
pas parler à la place des équipes
ministérielles simplement vous dire que
voilà on a comme vous l'imaginez
totalement sortis de notre chapeau les
propositions charge des produits et
discuter avec les équipes de en charge
de ces thématiques là et que je crois
que quelque part fort du succès tout de
même dû s'absenter
l'objectif de diminuer les restes à
charge et d'essayer d'identifier des
champs dans lesquels la démarche ou
quelque chose qui s'en inspirent sans
forcément la reproduire strictement sur
d'autres champs est assez largement
portée du côté de des équipes de
françois la de françois bonnet d'âne est
clairement là baudot donc après il ya
encore une fois je vais pas m'engager
pour eux mais je pense que c'est c'est
en tout cas ce fait d'instruire cesser
ces solutions là où ces propositions
sont assez largement partagée des
tellines d assez largement partagé avec
nos partenaires du ministère
s'agissant
s'agit sur la scène laisse
simplement
partager que nous nous comment dirais-je
assumons en réalité de plus en plus de
dossiers de gestion de la cds payante
puisque aujourd'hui quand vous regardez
les publics qui sont gérés par les
caisses perçu ces organismes
complémentaires sur 1,3 million de
bénéficiaires la c2 s entre guillemets
et ayant passé avec participation
l'assurance maladie en gère entre
guillemets aujourd'hui huit cent vingt
mille soit 61% et cette part là étant
assez forte augmentation depuis
maintenant 18 mois non pas par volonté
d'assurance maladie de prendre des parts
de marché ou d'être agressif entre
guillemets sur ce sujet là simplement un
certain nombre d'organismes
complémentaires et c'est leur choix ont
décidé de ne pas poursuivre cette ce
cette participation à la gestion de la
c2 s est donc de fait de toute façon par
définition nous nous prenons
heureusement tous les tous les assurés
et donc on voit cette part de gestion
par les caisses primaires augmentent et
voilà ce que je peux dire saisissant de
la grande sécu alors là pour le coup je
pas deux pas de scoop simplement mais ça
fait le lien avec ce que le disait ce
s'inspirait ou encore une fois du 100%
santé qui a vu une articulation organisé
cohérente des deux assureurs publics et
privés on va dire assure assurance
maladie obligatoire et assureurs
complémentaires se faire ça nous semble
être justement une voix cohérente de
d'articulation qui était déjà à
d'ailleurs évoqué dans le rapport du hk
même si peut-être le focus a été mis sur
d'autres propositions mais en tout cas
c'est bien dans cette logique là que
nous nous situons en rappelant également
que les sujets des du sujet des frais de
gestion des
pour les assureurs est un sujet qui pour
nous important est que nous continuons à
diminuer nos effectifs et donc abaisser
significativement nos frais de gestion
côté assurance maladie obligatoire ce
qui n'est pas le cas des organismes
complémentaires si vous regardez les
cinq dix quinze ou vingt dernières
années quel que soit le chant de recul
peut donc voudrait prendre on m'a
interrogé sur le contrôle et centre de
santé vous confirmer notre forte
mobilisation sur ces sujets là à la fois
sur le centre de santé visuelle et
ophtalmologiques vous dire pardon de le
dire comme ça j'ai dit quoi
un peu redondant donc
dentaire et ophtalmologique
ont plus d'une vingtaine de dépôts de
plaintes déjà enregistrés s'agissant des
centres visuels et des dépôts de plainte
des procédures ordinale ou de
déconventionnement qu'ils sont également
engagés s'agissant des centres de santé
dentaire nous augmentons
significativement notre volume de
contrôler
ces derniers ces derniers mois puisque
si je prends simplement les centres de
santé dentaire nous avons aujourd'hui
actuellement construit une cellule
nationale dédiée sur ces sujets là et
que nous avons actuellement plus d'une
quarantaine de contrôle de centres en
cours et que des contrôles coordonnés
ars assurances mali sont programmés pour
le deuxième semestre et nous avons par
ailleurs sur le centre de santé visuelle
à la fois engagé une démarche de
contrôle sur des centres entre
guillemets avec des soupçons de fraudes
les plus importants et puis ré enclenché
une action
de près contrôle je dirais de
sensibilisation avant contrôle depuis ce
que nous avons écrit à plus d'une
soixantaine de centres qui ont des
tarifs moyens élevés par rapport à une
activité comparable en les incitant
vivement à
ajuster leurs pratiques faute de quoi
nous engagerons des contrôles je partage
néanmoins avec vous le fait que les
leviers et puis nous avons par ailleurs
contre la malbouffe avec moi
enrichit la convention que l'avenant que
nous avons signé avec des centres de
santé il ya quelques mois d'un
renforcement du cahier des charges dans
le contenu du conventionnement mettre en
place ce conventionnement explicite qui
a été voté par la loi et de lui donner
davantage de contenu sur le l'écho des
contrats travail l'activité des
professionnels et puis une capacité
d'engager des sanctions plus rapidement
dès lors que nous enregistrions des
délais pour autant je permets de le dire
je ne pense pas que nous soyons
complètement au bout de ce sujet si
j'ose dire est que la question partie
des dispositifs avaient été censurés par
là par le conseil national pour motif de
cavaliers que nous soyons au bout d'une
régulation plus efficace de
l'installation des centres de santé
visuelle et dentaire qui aujourd'hui
s'installe de façon trop dynamique et
sans relation avec les besoins de santé
de la population il suffit de faire un
peu de vélo dans paris ou ailleurs pour
voir tout de même beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de centres jean terre ou au
créneau s'installer et je ne suis pas
certain que ce soit uniquement l'accès
aux soins qui soit le motif
d'installation de beaucoup de ces
centres donc nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire nous allons continuer à
amplifier nos actions de contrôle et on
est extrêmement déterminé là dessus mais
sans doute qu'il faudra avec le
gouvernement le parlement essayer
d'aller plus loin dans les mécanismes de
régulation
vous êtes trop de questions
merci monsieur le directeur là on va
prendre cinq commissaires une première
fois parce qu'il y en a encore cinq
autres alors jans jean sol ensuite
florence lassarade élisabeth doineau
berlin jamais à la maison et nous
passerons à une 2e brigade
madame la présidente monsieur le
directeur général j'ai en fait j'ai deux
trois questions avec ma collègue victor
jose mais nous avons rendu à la fin de
l'année dernière un rapport sur l'impact
de la crise sanitaire sur la santé
mentale des français
fusion alors état des préoccupations
importantes alors que les enquêtes
épidémiologiques montrent et de haut
niveau d'entités et d'états dépressifs
notamment en terme de situation
pouvez-vous nous dirons nous en sommes
pour les indicateurs que suivre la cnam
via le signe rome combien de
consultation rembourser deux psychiatres
ou psychologues combien de patients
concernés
concernant les médicaments avec le
groupement appui fort bon autonome est
membre quelles tendances constatées vous
sur la consommation de psychotropes par
exemple
deuxième question tirant les
conséquences de l'impact de la pandémie
et puis gohelle globalement des lacunes
connu et persistante de l'offre de soins
en santé mentale
ceci n'étant pas nouveau la loi de
financement pour 2022 a prévu la prise
en charge par l'assurance maladie deux
séances d'accompagnement par un
psychologue sur le dispositif lui-même
comment ce dispositif est une mise en
oeuvre quel bilan quel premier bilan
pouvez vous en faire et nous en dire
combien de psychologues ont sollicité à
ce jour le conventionnement spécifique
avec l'assurance maladie
concernant sa mobilisation par les
patients combien de personnes ont déjà
pu en bénéficier
quel est le profil des patients le
nombre des sciences prévu at il toujours
entièrement mobilisé les bénéficiaires
avaient ils déjà consulté auparavant un
psychologue ou un psychiatre ont fait
nous avions soulevés dans notre rapport
la question de l'adressage par un
médecin requis pour bénéficier de cette
prise en charge le dispositif était
inconnu des médecins et des patients
c'est pas toujours le retour nous avons
sur le terrain avez vous un retour
qualitatif la prise en charge at elle
était évaluée je vous remercie
très bien ensuite florence face à rades
merci madame la présidente
wadge ce qui me ce qui me laisse
perplexe c'est qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
prévention dans les années qui viennent
de se passer est que dans et que vous
n'évoquez pas ce sujet là et je je
m'interroge aussi en tant qu ancien
pédiatre sur les chiffres de mortalité
infantile en france qui sont parmi les
plus mauvais des pays européens
ce que ce que vous évoquez là le
l'espace santé pour remplacer le carnet
de santé bon je pense que les pédiatres
par exemple le france en difficulté le
pédiatre et le spécialiste de la non
prescription d'antibiotiques mais je
pense pas qu'on les ait spécialement
associé ni identifié comme le médecin
traitant de l'enfant je voulais savoir
quelles sont vos relations par exemple
avec l'association française de
pédiatrie ambulatoire si vous recourez à
cette structure qui est spécialement
spécialement bien organisée qui a été
anticipé beaucoup de sujets de l'enfant
que ça soit en matière d'orthodontie ou
de psychiatrie par exemple j'en profite
pour vous pour vous demander des
précisions sur le nouveau système mon
psy que vous évoquez et j'entends
effectivement l'autre jour avec le
conseil de l'ordre de la gironde et des
psychiatres qui m'ont expliqué qu'ils
avaient des structures qui se mettait en
place donc si vous pouviez développer un
un petit peu
je me disais en vous écoutant également
que le les histoires d'arrêt de travail
par téléconsultation ça a été en fait
beaucoup liés à l'épidémie et de kovy
death et la majeure partie une grande
partie des des arrêts de travail dans
les chiffres que vous citez est ce que
vous pouvez
différencier les arrêts de travail coct
vides et des autres voilà puis je je
j'aurai des tas de choses à à dire en
particulier que tant qu'on laisse le le
tarif du médecin traitant à 25 euros la
consultation et des spécialités comme la
pédiatrie également très peu très peu
technique et très clinique avec des
tarifs de consultation aussi bas là la
valorisation de l'adapter des médecins
par la rs au ps qu'on peut encore rester
sur ce système de deux bons points à la
fin de l'année si on a prescrit le bon
antibiotiques le monde entier perdent
sans ascenseur est-ce que c'est pas des
systèmes qui sont actuellement
complètement
obsolète et qu'il faudrait
qu'il faudrait relativiser au revoir je
ne parle pas du rang je vais pas rentrer
dans l'histoire du rendement où on nous
avait dit un assistant médical d'accord
vous passer de quatre consultations par
heure à 6 par leurs lauriers c'est un
peu ce que vous ce que vous évoquez
quand vous dites que le médecin traitant
n'a pas suffisamment de patients dans sa
patientèle moi je suis la première
concernée j'ai pas trouvé de médecin
traitant mais est ce que cette notion de
médecins référents finalement devrait
pas sauter parce que c'est pas la
question même qui fait que le médecin ne
peut pas prendre de malades
supplémentaires je m'arrête là un bien
élisabeth doineau et ensuite berlin
chaumié on s'arrêtera la presse m
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le directeur pour cette
présentation j'ai beaucoup apprécié
qu'effectivement il ya une synthèse dont
on a pu prendre connaissance parce que
le peu d'élèves voilà ne nous
permettaient pas de lire l'ensemble du
rapport mais je dois dire que je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention j'avais
j'avais regardé tous ces éléments
auparavant et j'ai l'impression un peu
que le baromètre est cassé quelque part
parce que entre ce que vous nous
décrivez monsieur le directeur et je
salue le travail technique à l travail
de rédaction et le travail de
présentation c'est remarquable mais
entre ce qui est dit sur le terrain ça
n'a rien à voir quoi tout le monde nous
nous rapporte à le manque de
professionnels de santé les difficultés
de coordination les difficultés de mise
en oeuvre vous avez l'ensemble des
propositions qui sont aussi présentés
mais toutes ces propositions ces outils
c'est parfait on va prendre inventer
d'autres mais sait comment les mettre en
oeuvre comment
cette stratégie elle n'est possible que
si nous avons des femmes et des hommes
pour voilà essayé
d'orchestrés tout ça sur le terrain donc
voilà vraiment je voudrais vous dire le
décalage qu'il ya entre ce qu'on entend
là est ce que nous nous avons comme
témoignage sur le terrain et c'est un
petit peu comme si voyez
on ne voyait plus finalement
l'excellence du système de santé
français alors qu'il existe parce que
quand on a des amis quand on a de la
famille d'aider des personnes que nous
rencontrons keaven qui vient de passer
une
difficulté de santé qui ont été pris en
charge à l'hôpital où peu importe par
des médecins etc ils nous disent leur
satisfaction mais finalement on ne voit
même plus ça dans le chaos dans lequel
nous sommes vraiment je voudrais dire
combien c'est compliqué aujourd'hui
c'est comme le dessin où on cherche
charlie et bien aujourd'hui on cherche
l'excellence de la santé en france de la
prise en charge de la santé en france et
moi je le regrette vraiment je regrette
vraiment parce que je pense que nous
avons les uns et les autres en tant
qu'élus locaux sans doute fait des
efforts considérables pour mettre en
oeuvre un certain nombre de choses et
qu'en fait aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu
après 2,2 deux périodes électorales là
c'était vraiment le sujet majeur qui
revenait continuellement c'est la
difficulté des français avoir justement
ce que propose
la france en termes de de santé donc moi
je voudrais vous dire ce décalage parce
qu'il existe vraiment et saissac
absolument qu'il faut que que nous ayons
en tête c'est cet énorme défi que nous
devons relever tous ensemble moi je
salue votre travail je salue le travail
des professionnels de santé qui font
qu'ils font le maximum mais là il ya
quelque chose qui est cassé il faut que
dans quelques plus vite possible on
retrouve charlie et quand on voit où l
excellence de la santé en france deux
questions qui me reviennent en résonance
du terrain c'est vraiment des questions
particulières la première c'est sur les
dispositifs
numériques innovants je crois qu'à un
décret en préparation les ppte est
d'ailleurs sorti ce sont des dispositifs
innovants qui permettent de soulager de
la douleur et qui devrait être prisé en
charge par l'assurance maladie c'est
très important parce qu'en france on a
peu travaillé sur la prise en charge
l'an passé et là il ya des dispositifs
numériques qui qui sont comment créer
par des start up il faut absolument
justement soulagé parce qu'au lieu de
prendre des médicaments il vaut mieux
avoir ce petit de dispositifs et le
deuxième co psy que j'ai pu relever sur
le terrain c'est que pour les personnes
handicapées la prise en charge des
fauteuils roulants là ça vraiment ça
fait peur avec ses 50 délais surtout
pour les enfants en fait on fait plus
attention d'après ce qu'on me dit au
prix plutôt qu'à la pathologie et au
fait que mais l'enfant grandit donc ça
c'est deux crocs auquel il faut faire
attention
pour ce qui est des équipes médicales
moi je suis tout à fait pour mais je
pense au contraire qu'il faut plus de
temps quand on fait un travail
pluridisciplinaire autour d'un malade
parce qu'il faut préparer les réunions
il faut il faut en faire l'analyse et il
faut faire des conclusions de prise en
charge après mais sur le coup je pense
que c'est pas on pourra pas passer de
1000 à 1200 patients comme ça d'un coup
de baguette magique parce que la prise
en charge par équipes elle demande aussi
beaucoup d'investissements sur le plan
humain sur le plan du temps voilà mes
quelques remarques merci merci pour
terminer bernard jomier
merci à présidente merci beaucoup
monsieur le directeur général pour vous
ce rapport extrêmement intéressant comme
mes collègues j'en ai eu la synthèse et
je puis je ne suis pas allé me plonger
dans l'intégralité du rapport j'ai trois
remarques et trois questions mais
remarque d'abord sur l'équilibré général
corinne imbert a rappelé que les
exonérations
qui encore se profile à l'horizon
législatives vont compliquer encore le
retour à l'équilibré voire aggraver le
déficit de la sécurité sociale faudrait
aussi rappelé que outre cet oxygène dont
ont pu placer qu on lui a mis des
boulets aux pieds en transférant la
dette à la cades s est que ces boules et
là il pèse très lourd en nombre de
milliards donc au total effectivement ça
devient un choix politique deuxièmement
sur les téléconsultations moi je veux
dire je souscris à ce que vous ce que
vous exposez on est en dérivant et on le
voit quotidiennement de cette pratique
et la dérive se transforme en pression
sur les professionnels prescripteurs
quotidienne pour obtenir des arrêts de
travail vous l'avez mentionné ou des
prescriptions dans des conditions qui ne
remplissent plus des conditions de
sécurité sanitaire en plus donc c'est
inquiétant et moi je regrette cette
prolongation de trois mois du
remboursement à 100% d'été consultation
qui ne changera rien à la situation d
urgence mais qui fait que c'est un
régime de remboursement
préférentiel par rapport à la
consultation en présentiel
la troisième et dernière remarque c'est
que pareil je souffrais ce que vous vous
exposez qu'il existe encore des outils
pour gagner du temps médical sur la
question des de l'offre de soin et des
déserts médicaux mais nous sommes
beaucoup trop lent et beaucoup trop
parcimonieux dans l'application de ces
outils est là où je veux attirer votre
attention mais vous le savez c'est que
le résultat c'est que la tentation
autoritaire elle croit et elle croit y
compris chez les parlementaires elle
croît dans une situation politique
instable elle pourrait bien finir par
des bouchers je veux dire la sur les
mesures à prendre or je suis aussi
profondément convaincus qu'il n'ya
aucune amélioration à attendre des
mesures d' autoritarisme ça ne marche
pas et la tentation autoritaire c'est un
mythe quand un problème dure depuis trop
longtemps que tout le monde est exaspéré
ulcéré eh bien on en vient là donc
fait tout c'est pas que devaux ressort
votre sort mais que pour ces leviers qui
disent que ces leviers qui existe comme
l'a dit élisabeth doineau il ne dresse
pas dans la théorie mais ils soient
développées de façon massive et
rapidement sur le terrain parce
qu'effectivement j'ai trois questions
rapides la première elle porte encore
une fois sur l'offre de soins vous
indiquez dans votre document que la
convention médicale sera un rendez vous
important pour adopter des dispositifs
est-ce que vous avez mis en place des
processus pour en amont de l'adoption de
cette convention qui est mono
catégorielles qui ne concerne que les
médecins pour discuter avec l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé concernés
parce que ces dispositifs concernent
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
dont comment menez-vous au ce travail là
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question porte sur ce qui vous expliquer
dans le document donc que suite au vote
en 2018 de loi la loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale de son article 51
certain nombre d'expérimentations été
menées et que certaines allaient rentrer
dans le droit commun vous ont préparé la
rentrée dans droit commun quelles sont
les lignes principales
quels sont les changements les plus
importants qui vont rentrer dans le
droit commun pardon c'est peut-être dans
le document détaillé mais comme je n'ai
pas lu et ma troisième et dernière
question c'est que dans la lutte contre
la fraude
vous indiquez un montant que vous
souhaitez récupérer 300 millions d'euros
il y à une fraude par sue fracturation
allégués avec des arguments sérieux qui
porte sur plusieurs millions d'euros à
l'institut hospitalo universitaires
méditerranée cette fraude là avez vous
ouvert une enquête avez-vous pris des
mesures car le s exerce principalement
au détriment de l'assurance maladie et
seconde errements au détriment des
organismes complémentaires je n'ai à
macau annexes je n'ai pas connaissance
au jour d'aujourd'hui que vous ayez pris
des mesures pour récupérer ces
surfacturations d'abord pour en attester
la véracité mais elles semblent soit
solide voilà à l'heure où la haine sm et
l'igas font enfin leur travail et que
leurs rapports sont poursuivis plein sm
qui est définitif absolument cinglant et
pour celui de liga ce n'est pas encore
définitivement pas ce qu'on en a lu
inquiétant sur les dérives de lee a chu
voilà quelle mesure vous prenez vous
merci beaucoup de questions vous select
se laisse répondre ensuite nous aurons
encore 4
merci beaucoup monsieur monsieur le
sénateur sur la sur la santé mentale qui
rejoint d'ailleurs d'autres d'autres
questions quelques éléments tout d'abord
point d'étape sur le dispositif de prise
en charge des séances de psychologues
sont disponibles mais aussi entre
guillemets qui est encore à disputer
finalement extrêmement récent puisque
les psychologues sont rentrés dans
dispositif de conventionnement depuis
février et que le dispositif a commencé
à être ouvert à la prescription et à la
prise en charge depuis avril donc on a
vraiment évidemment quelques quelques
premiers mois de recul et ses premiers
mois sont assez intéressants et
encourageants d'ores et déjà près de
plus de 1600 psychologues sont
aujourd'hui conventionné pour prendre en
charge ces patients donc anciennement
quelques semaines on a déjà un volume de
psychologues concerné intéressant et ses
inscriptions
continuent chaque semaine de nouveaux
psychologue s'inscrivent donc on est sur
une dynamique favorable et il me semble
que la quasi totalité des départements
est maintenant un couvert par des
psychologues ce que je peux vous dire
également c'est preque près de deux
mille huit cent cinquante médecins ont
d'ores et déjà
utilisé cette possibilité de
prescription et redis mon attachement à
ce que ce dispositif s'inscrivent
d'ailleurs un parcours de soins
organiser une prescription d'un médecin
versez cette prise en charge
de deux psychologues et pour un total à
ce stade de 5500 séance donc ce voilà le
bilan intermédiaire
sachant qu évidemment ça monte en charge
encore une fois de façon intéressante
mais encore une fois très récente nous
avons fait un effort significatif
d'information d'accompagnement des
projets concernés avec les d'emailing
identifié vers l'ensemble des des
médecins pour possiblement prescripteurs
nous accompagnons les psychologues qui
choisissent de ce conventionnés nous
travaillons également avec les ars pour
mieux faire connaître le dispositif
auprès des psychologues qui ne sont pas
encore complètement inscrit mais voilà
première premier bilan d'étape encore
une fois d'un dispositif qu'il ya
quelques semaines seulement 2 de durée
de vie si j'ose dire mais qui nous
semblent encourageants et qui va
progressivement on a des retours
extrêmement intéressant qualitativement
de des professionnels concernés qui
attendait depuis longtemps la
possibilité de recourir à des soins de
psychologues sans exposer des patients
des restes à charge puisque auparavant
il n'avait pas de prise en charge ce qui
fait échos d'ailleurs avec une question
que vous évoquez des éléments qui sont
dans le rapport qu'ils sont plutôt
préoccupant de l'impact de sur la santé
mentale des français de de déconfinement
successifs et duco vide mais vous l'avez
évoqué également dans votre rapport des
derniers chiffres et notamment sur
l'année de 8 21 sur la prescription
d'antidépresseurs chez des jeunes chez
les 0 20 ans sont en nette augmentation
près de 13% d'augmentation entre 2021 et
2020 ce qui est un élément signal d'
alerte à prendre en compte nous allons
réengager auprès des médecins notamment
généralistes une campagne
d'accompagnement sur la santé mentale à
la fois pour valoriser les sujets
justement séance de psychologues essayez
de re faire partager des bonnes
pratiques en matière de prescription de
médicaments sur ces sujets là mais nous
développons également tout ce qui tourne
autour de vous savez ce qui s'appelle
les premiers secours santé mentale qui
est une pratique qui est assez bien
développer dans d'autres pays et que
nous finançons aujourd'hui dans
notamment dans les milieux
universitaires et que nous voulons
développer au delà notamment dans le
monde du travail de former des gens à
l'identification premier premiers
secours comme comme ça indique de
d'identification de possibles troubles
et d'accompagnement dans le système de
soins
madame la sénatrice ou m'interdit alors
je suis allé trop vite sur le rapport ce
qui est bien je me permets de revenir
sur le cas beaucoup de mesures sur la
prévention on en rapport s'il a évoqué
un certain nombre de choses sur la
famille et des enfants il ya tout un
développement également sur le dépistage
organisé des cancers quand même une
politique de prévention majeur sur
lequel notre pays est en retard sur
lequel nous proposons dans la continuité
des rapports de l'igas sur
l'organisation des dépistages de de
modifier l'organisation de simplifier
les processus de ne confier les
invitations de systématiser les
démarches vers qui n'existe pas encore
suffisamment aujourd'hui est de faire
sur le dépistage des cancers organise
elle organise des concerts ce qu'on a
fait sur les vaccinations covin une
vraie démarche systématique d'aller vers
dans les territoires en retard dont les
populations les plus éloignés du système
de soins voilà quelques exemples de
prévention sur les sujets enfants
pédiatre je me permets de souligner deux
ou trois choses d'une part dans le
rapport justement nous évoquons le fait
la nécessité de soutenir notamment les
développements de maison de santé avec
des pédiatres aujourd'hui les maisons de
santé sont avant tout construit autour
des médecins généralistes on veut
soutenir des projets en gros deux
maisons de la santé de l'enfant avec des
pédiatres avec d'autres métiers de
l'enfance avec des orthophonistes
orthoptistes avec l'ensemble de ces
professionnels c'est une proposition
identifié du rapport rappeler également
que nous partageons avec vous le
diagnostic que la pédiatrie fait partie
des spécialités cliniques qui sont pour
dire des choses en bas de l'échelle des
revenus des spécialités de ce pays ce
qui n'est pas normal c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans l'avenant numéro 9
signé en juillet dernier et qui est mis
en oeuvre maintenant pleinement depuis
le mois d'avril 2009 ne nous avons
fortement revalorisé le tarif des
consultations des pédiatres ce qui
représente une augmentation annuelle des
honoraires des pédiatres en moyenne de
plus de 5000 euros une augmentation
inédite inédite des honoraires des
pédiatres des financements d'assurance
maladie dans notre pays et que il est
probable que ce ne soit pas pour le coup
je vous rejoins madame la sénatrice la
fin l'histoire si j'ose dire est que
nous aurons sans doute à continuer cette
politique de soutien à des spécialités
cliniques comme la piedad pédiatrie ya
aussi la psychiatrie d'ailleurs qui a
bénéficié de mesures financières et doit
continuer à en bénéficier parce que nous
avons besoin de spécialités cliniques
attractive dans notre dans notre pays
s'agissant 2
de la mortalité infantile ne veut pas
botté en touche en attendant on a
partagé diagnostic mais qui a été établi
par les autorités sanitaires de ce pays
le ministère il travaille l'aider les
causalités de ces indicateurs qui sont
en effet pas orientés favorablement sont
sans doute multiples et difficiles à
établir
on participera de notre côté à toute
mesure à la fois des gnostiques et
d'accompagnement mais pas d'élément
complètement nouveau a évoqué avec vous
ce matin madame madame nationale jeu
devrait dissiper entraîne un éventuel
malentendu
je crois que l'assurance lundi essaye en
tous les cas d'être parfaitement
consciente
des difficultés que traversent nos
systèmes de santé et pour se dire les
choses aussi à la fois de la violence du
choc qui a représenté le coc vide non
pas et non pas seulement le coc vide en
lui-même mais l'ensemble de ses effets
collatéraux à court et moyen terme on
évoqué tout à l'heure la santé mentale
on voit bien que sur le sur les
hospitalisations programme et l'impact a
été aussi significatif on voit bien que
toute une série de programmes de
prévention ont été plus ou moins stopper
l'activité des professionnels a été
perturbé et donc le choc il et il est
extrêmement fort et donc il est nous
l'avons nous en avons bien conscience
dans un contexte où par ailleurs que qui
était déjà évidemment relativement
entendus deuxième élément est donc ça
nous n'avons pas vraiment conscience
deuxième élément ça n'est pas un
phénomène purement français c'est pas
pour ça que c'est c'est pour ça que
c'est rassurant c'est pas pour ça ça
nous aide mais on voit dans d'autres la
quasi totalité des pays comparables
s'être les maths cette problématique
d'attractivité des professions de santé
de départ significatif de vacance de
poste de difficultés des systèmes voilà
je pense qu'il faut se le dire aussi ce
n'est pas le système français en
lui-même qui est en cause c'est le fait
que l'ensemble des systèmes
on voit là le des effets retard du pôle
iiid produisent notamment sur le sujet
ressources humaines des effets très
significatif mais de ce point de vue là
je voudrais rebondir sur un teint comme
que vous avez utilisé c'est un énorme
défi et nous pensons que
c'est pas le propos que vous avez tenus
avec eux on peut partager la gravité de
la situation mais au delà de la gravité
l'association c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
en face et nous pensons que nous pouvons
nous assurance maladie mais évidemment
aux côtés des pouvoirs publics aux côtés
du ministre la ministre déléguée au coût
de marsan des acteurs de santé a porté
toute une série de réponses et mémé qui
ne rejoint pas ce que c'est un tableau
mais ne sont pas complètement novatrice
pas besoin d'inventer des choses
complètement nouvelle on a besoin da
réussir à les déployer plus fortement et
plus efficacement
voilà pourquoi on a entre guillemets que
3500 assistants médicaux dans notre pays
parce que ça n'a que deux ou trois ans
parce que le coc vidame aussi perturbé
les choses et mais on va fortement
allégé des contraintes de tourner au
dispositif améliorer les paramètres
accompagner les médecins et nous sommes
confiants sur le fait que l'on doit
pouvoir le déployer beaucoup plus vite
donc
on a quand même deux fois plus de
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires en
2022 qu'en 2017 mais on sait qu'on a 15%
des prochaines de santé aujourd'hui deux
villes qui exercent en maisons de santé
et on doit encore accélérer ce mouvement
donc on pense effectivement que voilà il
ya un certain nombre de solutions qu'il
faut sans doute accéléré je pense que le
gouvernement lancera certainement de
travaux de concertation autour de ces
thématiques là et on verse à ses
concertations et à ce débat public est
éminemment dans le débat parlementaire
toute une série de propositions que qui
sont dans le dans leurs rapports même je
vous rejoins bien orienté sur le fait
que le défi est immense sur les
dispositifs numériques notamment de
prise en charge des patients de la
douleur et sa rage je me permets là
aussi sans fin sans me faire uniquement
le vrp du rapport d évoquer je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas dit dans la synthèse que
nous faisons une proposition de pour
identifier de façon maintenant simple et
efficace
une troisième catégorie de prise en
charge en tant que produit santé il ya
aujourd'hui des médicaments les
dispositifs médicaux nous proposons de
réfléchir à la mise en place d'une
troisième catégorie kz qu'on a appelé
les thérapies digital on peut trouver un
autre nom hein mais en gros de tout ce
qui tourne autour de l'utilisation de
solutions numériques ça peut être des
bases de données sap eu des allures
rythme ça peut aider application ça peut
être des outils qui deviennent d aider
d'aider des briques de prise en charge
des patients utilisé par les prochaines
de santé et aujourd'hui on tourne autour
on fait déjà un certain nombre de choses
avec les dispositifs médicaux quand on
fait rentrer des dix possibles et
médicaux dans la prise en charge du
remboursement on a souvent de plus en
plus du numérique de la télésurveillance
avec mais on sent bien que ça ne suffit
pas on propose d'aller plus loin pour
identifier une solution une une
catégorie en tant que tel qu'on a
appelée thérapiste digital donc qui
pourrait servir à prendre en charge les
solution que vous évoquez monsieur
sénateurs juillet le peut-être je me
permets de se déchirer mixa a été
évoquée également je crois pas par
madame un reporter le sur les
exonérations de cotisations sociales
prévues par le texte son pouvoir d'achat
je crois d'ailleurs que le ministre du
soft hier soir tard à l'assemblée
l'occasion y compris de le confirmer et
compris de 2,2 de prononcer la sagesse
du gouvernement sur un amendement
parce que en réalité les exonérations
prévues par le texte ont bien compensé à
la sécurité sociale comme c'est
maintenant le cas de manière je crois à
peu près systématique et donc les manque
de recettes noir mais je vous imaginez
bien que nous y veillons également de
notre côté mais je crois que ce qui est
aussi fait pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat soutenir l'emploi est aussi
potentiellement des gains de recettes
pour la sécu a décidé pour l'assurance
maladie sur la téléconsultation je veux
je ne reviens pas très rapidement je
pense par une fois comme comme vous ces
sénateurs qu'il est temps de bâtir à 4
le croient que la situation particulière
de l'été justifié on va dire peut-être
une dernière prolongation de ces mesures
à 100% mais qu' il faut maintenant avec
l'ensemble des acteurs construire une
place plus pérenne sur les
ses solutions de télé constatations et
leur place dans le parcours de soin sur
les trois questions que vous évoquez
sur la convention médicale on a bien en
tête de 2,2 d'avoir des moments des
temps de concertation avec les autres
professions de santé d'ailleurs je ne
signale que dans les négociations que
nous avons eues avec les pharmaciens sur
la convention pharmaciens nous avons
échangé en amoureux des médecins et des
infirmiers sur des sujets d'intérêt
commun sur la vaccination sur
l'accompagnement la sur les discussions
que nous avons avec les syndicats
d'infirmiers libéraux sur les ip a
notamment et sur la vaccination et la
télésanté nous avons discuté pas plus
tard que la semaine dernière avec les
médecins pour partager un point d'étape
avec eux et donc il est bien clair que
nous aurons des temps d'échangés avec
les autres professions de santé et
d'ailleurs plus largement nous avons
engagé un travail de 2-2-2 d'écouté 2 et
2,2
de partage avec l'ensemble des acteurs
du système de santé intéressés par ces
sujets là par nos limites et un dialogue
même si l'avant fructueux avec nos
partenaires syndicats médicaux sur
l'article 51 vous m'interrogez sur le
sur le passage de droit commun je veux
je me permet de partager les gouttes
d'or c'est déjà ce ce passage-là
s'organise puisque pour prendre deux
exemples y compris très récent dans la
loi de finances en national pour 2022 le
dispositif qu'on appelle retrouve-t-on
cap prévention de l'obésité chez les
enfants et les adolescents étaient
indisponibles à 51 qui a été généralisé
dans la loi de financement deuxième
exemple la télésurveillance vous savez
qu'on a commencé par tout ce qui est
mécanisme étape avec 51 et que le
mécanisme de prise en charge à
télésurveillance est passé dans le droit
commun dans la loi de financement pour
2022 et clairement tout ce que nous
avons proposé nous avons commencé à
proposer un rapport sur l'exercice
coordonner les modes de financement
autour de ça ça s'est nourri également
par des dispositifs pardon du titre
d'acronymes mais irep et pep's de
financement d'exercice coordonnée
notamment autour des équipes de soins
traitantes et que ce sera sûrement des
sujets que nous ont aussi dans la
convention médicale de voir dans quelles
conditions nous pouvons tirer des
enseignements de ces écrivains mentation
d'artistes et un pour les mettre dans le
droit commun de la convention médicale
sur l'ia chu marseille simplement
partager avec vous deux éléments d'une
part l'assurance maladie a suspendu
depuis mars 2001 l'ensemble des
contrôles de la taille des haies sur
l'activité et les a pas repris
en accord avec le ministère de la santé
ou plutôt d'ailleurs la demande du
ministère de la santé depuis maintenant
plus de deux ans donc ces contrôles ont
été suspendus sur l'ensemble des
hôpitaux et d'autres néanmoins nous
avons engagé depuis plusieurs semaines
des échanges avec eux
les hôpitaux de marseille pour avoir des
éléments pour comprendre les niveaux de
facturation des hospitalisations de jour
qui nous semble le plus élevé
aux hôpitaux de marseille qu'ailleurs et
nous attendons des retours des
compléments d'explications sur ces
sujets là pour le calaisien ont engagé
des démarches nécessaires
alors
la milonga n'est pas le savoir et
pascale gruny nains des slogans annick
jacquemet président mais non oui merci
mais me présente je directeur d'abord
merci pour pour ce rapport
particulièrement intéressant comme mes
collègues je voulais pas lui j'ai lu la
synthèse et j'ai trouvé ces synthèses
passionnante dois vous dire
mon problème je voulais vous poser trois
questions liées à chu mais donc ces
faits et la politique conventionnelle
s'est fait également mais sur la
politique conventionnelle
je suis d'accord avec vous il faut
intégrer l'ensemble des professionnels
de santé dans le peut-être pas dans la
négociation mais au moins dans les
travaux après une pré négociation et en
particulier les jeunes médecins qui se
plaignent souvent ne pas être introduit
dans la politique conventionnelle
je ferme la parenthèse et je reviens sur
ma dernière question donc celles qui
fâchent
je vous ai dit que j'avais apprécié
l'ensemble de vos propositions parce
qu'on est presque vous it dire que ça
aurait pu faire partie d'un programme
présidentiel
cela dit beaucoup d'organismes officiels
font chaque année chacun dans son coin
des propositions pour améliorer les la
santé publique et la santé en france et
dans ces conditions les votes étant
particulièrement intéressante je pose ma
question y at il encore un intérêt à
l'existence de la direction générale de
la santé
non pas tout
merci mène la présidente à monsieur le
directeur général moi je vais commencer
aussi vous dire que le premier sujet
sincèrement quand on est sûr sur le sur
le terrain pour nous c'est la santé moi
je suis dans le département de l'aisne
donc bien sûr en zones sous denses et on
est de toute façon mal lotis sur
pratiquement tous les sujets mais celui
là est vraiment la priorité
laurent sadique avait pas de médecin
traitant je n'en ai pas non plus je fais
une heure et demie de voiture pour aller
chez un dentiste je fais une heure de
voiture pour aller chez un ophtalmo
voilà c'est moi bien entendu je pourrais
je pourrais avoir voilà
lé plus près et je fais la même chose
moi je suis citoyen lambda donc pour
vous dire que c'est compliqué en ce
moment en période de vacances
mais nous max ne sont pas remplacés
il trouve plus de remplaçants moi j'ai
un beau frère médecin pour pas de
remplaçant la trop de patients et vous
dites il faut qu'ils prennent davantage
de patients va prendre sa retraite l'an
prochain un sujet aussi les
remplacements la retraite ils ont droit
aussi à se reposer quand vous avez plus
de 60 patients par jour je pense que le
repos c'est bien et les remplaçants ils
veulent pas venir dans dans des cabinets
où il ya autant de deux patients et
autant de travail il en faut 2 3 pour le
remplacer et donc quand il va partir à
la retraite
mais il y aura personne donc c'est un
vrai sujet et la population elle n'en
peut plus à le soigner c'est important
mais maintenant je vais devenir sur sur
un autre sujet c'est la prévention vous
dites que vous en avez parlé voilà si
vous avez répondu à ma collègue florence
lassarade sur le sujet et sur le
dépistage il d'épissage ça veut dire oui
on va trouver la personne qui a un début
de cancer mais comment on fait pour pas
avoir le cancer et la prévention c'est
largement à moi j'apprécie par exemple
je vais vous dire dans les
semaines leur taux plein iq un simple
parce que ça sur les problèmes de dos
c'est très important que les enfants et
des semelles orthopédiques
seulement est ce que tout le monde le
sait ça qui a pas de restes à charge je
sais pas moi j'm'en la population vous
avez est très éloignée de beaucoup de
choses l'orthodontie eux aussi moi je
pense que c'est aujourd'hui plus
important c'est à dire augmenter le
nombre de patients pour pour les
médecins banon c'est peut-être éviter
qu'ils aient moins de consultation parce
que justement ils seront moins malade et
pourront travailler davantage aura moins
d'arrêt de travail mais la prévention
c'est patrice pas c'est pas très vendeur
pour pour un programme présidentiel
voyez pas ce que la prévention va
peut-être on le verra dans vingt ans que
qu'on a fait des efforts donc mais je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet non de
travailler sur le bien vieillir dans ma
région parce qu'on a un sujet aussi et
le bien vieillir donc on a une
application en parliez effectivement du
digital on va mettre en place une
application pour que les personnes et on
espère à partir de 60 ans puisse évaluer
en fait et puis effectivement qu'on
évite a finalement qui soir on n'est pas
trop tôt et qui se ferait et un dernier
point pour rebondir ce que je ne crois
pas que j'ai entendu de réponse sur le
handicap sur la prise en charge du
handicap à ma collègue élisabeth doineau
sur le fauteuil roulant moi je vais vous
dire sur les chiens si moi je connais
quelqu'un finalement heureusement qu'il
ya des associations qui prennent en
charge
wilshere aveugle oui oui les chiens
d'aveuglés à excuser moi fallait que je
précise
excusez moi
non maintenant c'est sa deuxième sujet
voilà merci beaucoup
l'aviation go oui merci madame la
présidente je rajoute aussi une petite
touche moi je suis élu dans la nièvre
dans quelques jours on aura plus de
dermatologues du tout dans le
département donc en effet c'est vrai que
le tableau est quand même très
inquiétant pour les populations et alors
là c'est un sujet qui ne dépend pas de
nous mais j'insiste sur le fait qu'il
faut que les jeunes de nos territoires
au et accès aux formations médicales
études de santé parce que s'ils sont
tous formés en ville il ya assez peu de
chances qu'un jour ils viennent
s'installer à neuvy sur loire alors moi
j'avais deux questions précises vous
avez beaucoup parlé du sujet de la
démographie des infirmiers
on en forme beaucoup actuellement on en
a formé 100000 non seulement la
difficulté c'est qu'ils arrêtent de plus
en plus vite donc d'après les chiffres
que j'ai il en manque 60 milles mais on
en a 180 milles qui n'exerce pas est-ce
que des actions sont projetées sont en
cours pour essayer de rétablir le
dialogue avec ces professionnels savoir
si l'élastique est définitivement cassé
au sinon si on peut les ramener à
exercer leur profession ou quelqu'un en
fait quelque part on a un gisement
énorme sous le pied et deuxième question
certaines choses sont conditionnés pour
les médecins généralistes
par exemple je pense à la possibilité
d'avoir des assistants médicaux au fait
de prendre des patients supplémentaires
mais ils ne peuvent pas on l'a dit à
plusieurs endroits ils sont au taquet
donc est-ce qu'on peut revoir les
négociations qui on a déjà été menée
avec eux parce que ils ont besoin plus
qu'une maison de quelques pas ceux qui
ont le plus besoin d'assistants pour
faire des équipes et gagner du temps
médical n'y ont plus accès parce qu'ils
sont déjà à saturation merci
oui merci présidente
merci aussi monsieur le directeur pour
les documents vous nous avez fait passer
et la clarté de vos propos alors j'aurai
quelques petites questions
que pensiez-vous et que faites vous pour
la redondance des examens j'ai un
chiffre en tête qui est de 30% alors on
parle de déficit des comptes voilà c'est
en arriver à réduire cette redondance
d'examens on arriverait déjà faire
quelques économies deuxième proposition
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez et
c'est peut-être pas
possible dans le milieu médical mais
chez les vétérinaires ce n'est pas le
vétérinaire traitant qui gère les
autopsies chez les animaux pour éviter
justement une pression pour éviter que
les assurances n'est à prendre en charge
une vache foudroyé qui n'est pas
foudroyé et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile pour un vétérinaire traitant
de refuser certaines pressions est ce
qu'on n'a pas la même chose en médecine
à savoir que et j'ai certaines remontées
d'un médecin qui me disent vin c'est
vrai que des fois on a du mal à refuser
alors est ce qu'il est envisageable que
des arrêts de travail au moins des
renouvellements d'arrêt de travail soit
effectué par un confrère qui n'est pas
le médecin traitant troisième question
effectivement sur la prise en charge des
fauteuils roulants vous n'aviez pas
répondu et ça m'amène à une autre
question quand j'étais première vice
présidente du conseil départemental du
doubs en charge des solidarités
j'avais été mis en relation avec une
personne handicapée qui avait un
fauteuil et puis je lui ai demandé tient
en fait combien coup de ton fauteuil il
m'a dit 40 mille euros parce qu'il
devait le remplacer deux ans après je
lui ai dit mais que devient ce fauteuil
mme di bari 1 1 et par à la casse et
donc j'ai mis trois ans pour mettre en
place dans le département du doubs une
structure de
récupération de recyclage et de revente
de ce matériel là
on a fait bénéficier aussi à une
entreprise d'insertion d'un peu plus de
travail on est dans l'économie
circulaire sauf consoeur maintenant à
une problématique c'est que tout ce
matériel là il n'y a aucune prise en
charge
sur du matériel d'occasion alors est ce
que vous pensez à
y réfléchir et quelle solution pouvait
vous proposer parce que
je comprends bien que les fabricants
de matériel voit d'un mauvais oeil
arriver l'occasion sur le marché mais
voilà qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour justement faciliter la
commercialisation de cette ce matériel
de seconde main merci
oui merci même présente ses directoires
d'abord un grand merci pour votre
présentation et la synthèse 3,3 sujet
lors je ne veux pas être trop insolent
et les fauteuils roulants eu beaucoup
d'interventions laissé clair que à un
des points particuliers dans la réforme
la mise en place du décret qui pose un
nombre d'interrogations tous les cas
dans les projections sur le lait les
taux de rotation durée d'utilisation et
puis le la gestion des fauteuils bon
c'est à un vrai débat qui a beaucoup
inquiété en tout cas le le le monde des
associations de des personnes
handicapées moi j'aimerais revenir
toujours survolées handicap sont pleines
de de recherche d'économies sur la
cohérence en matière de gestion des
transports des personnes handicapées en
matière de transport de temps pour les
enfants handicapés
lorsque ces sons dans le cadre de
consultations
c'est l'assurance maladie qui finance
lorsqu'on est à la scolarisation c'est
le département qui organise qui finance
lorsqu'on est en établissement c'est les
dotations deux établissements qui
organise et finance et lorsque parfois
on est soudé activités extérieures sur
les familles urbanistes qui financent et
je pense qu'il reste certainement
matière de coordination et en matière en
tous les cas déficiences des moyens un
vrai sujet qui est à mettre sur la table
et on rappelle que plus le nombre
d'enfants concernés c'est une boisson
dernière question on a beaucoup parlé de
2,2 de gestion de 2 de la dépense
il ya un volet qui autour de thé des
problématiques de fraude autour des
dépenses nous avions porté ici ne ppl
concernant les carburants et des cartes
vitale biométrique à l'époque nous
l'avions transformer parce que il y
avait une expérimentation en cours donc
aux amateurs d'applications est ce que
vous allez premier autour de ces
expériences par rapport aux enjeux de
recherche diminution de la proton
merci alors moi j'ai des petites
questions sur les greffes et maintenant
pour que vous puissiez répondre
globalement
sur les assistants médicaux lorsqu'on a
fait le rapport sur la de la commission
des requêtes hôpital et on avait
d'ailleurs échangé sur ce point là
il faut assouplir le dispositif
ça a été dit à la fois mais même sur la
formation des revenus est ce que là vous
allez vraiment le faire sur le sens pour
61 points
c'est que la cour des comptes à laquelle
nous avions demandé un rapport sur le
100 % santé va nous le rendre la semaine
prochaine le le 27 en commission
j'avais des points un peu concernant des
auditions des rencontres rassemblent que
j'ai fait on a fait une table ronde sur
la transplantation d'organes et on nous
a dit qu'il n'y avait pas d' approche
médico économique entre la greffe et la
dialyse
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
éléments
nous sommes à lèvres et des collègues à
la fondent à l'institut curie et puis au
centre des cordeliers avec corinne
aubert centre de recherche des
cordeliers un sujet qui revient toujours
c'est celui du riz à chaîne
les tests compagnons c'est vraiment
galère pour les équipes de recherche les
équipes soignantes est-ce que ça a
progressé dans la proposition de loi
qu'on avait déposé à canet d'helmand et
qui a été votée récemment en février on
avait mis un système un dispositif en
place
j'espère ce sera poursuivie à
l'assemblée nationale mais où est-ce
qu'on menait et puis
des points sur la prévention
j'ai reçu la conférence nationale de
l'accident vasculaire cérébral a évoqué
mais je crois que le président de la
république l'avait mis d'ailleurs dans
son programme une visite de prévention à
l'âge de 45 ans 45 ans avec notamment la
prévention des accidents les accidents
vasculaires
je pense que c'est majeur et la
conférence nationale de l'avc avait des
chiffres très intéressants à ce sujet et
j'ai reçu récemment l'association des
hypercholestérolémie familiale qu'il a
aussi milité pour un dépistage précoce
mais non par en cascade ou ya un cas
dans la famille on teste tout le monde
est vraiment un dépistage universel si
je puis dire de l'hypercholestérolémie
familiale avec un retour et une baisse
possible de deux trous vasculaires et
autres est ce qu'il ya des réflexions de
la caisse sur ce sujet et puis un
dernier point ce qui m'a fait penser
c'est la redondance des actes moi je
suis frappé que lorsqu'on va faire des
examens radiologiques en faire leur part
une radio de la figo je redis pour la
droite vous reviendrai la semaine
prochaine mais un peu ça quand même moi
je pense qu'il ya des dérives de sujets
là moi j'étais un peu surprise en
maintenant h ces offres en allant d'un
centre de radiologie ou la radiologue
très clairement on m'a dit vous revenez
à semaine prochaine mais on vous fera
toutes les radios possible en même temps
parce que ça coûte moins cher à la
sécurité sociale je trouvais que c'était
bien mais c'est quand même pas le cas
partout et je pense qu'il est il ya des
économies à faire sur ce point et puis
pour les données de santé oms lance une
mission d'information de la commission
sur les données de santé on aura
l'occasion à ce qu'on pourrait entendre
à ce sujet là et je veux pas aborder
d'ores et déjà avec est sûr qu'il y
avait sur ce surprenant voilà monsieur
le directeur
sur les jeunes médecins d'abord vous
rassurer si je peux entre les caves
d'abord confirmé que la fois d'ailleurs
les étudiants et les jeunes médecins
internes sont bien associés à la
négociation a même depuis leurs années
dans le cadre de la convention ils sont
pleinement associés alors il n'y a pas
un état mais ils sont présents dans les
négociations que nous avons donc
comme tout jeune étudiant et ça va faire
entendre leur voix
mais je suis sûr qu'ils le feront encore
cette fois-ci
sur
alors sur notre relation de l'art de la
santé vous imaginez bien que je
peux mais y compris au regard de ce que
nous avons vécu sur le colis de se
baigner la mobilisation très forte de
cette direction en est un cas sur ans
maladie sur tous les sujets
contacts racing vaccination et la
mobilisation de la droite et donc je
vous confirme que nous avons besoin
d'une direction générale de la santé
sentez vous serez pas surpris de ma
réponse
mais qui est évidemment sincère
sur
et y compris d'ailleurs sur le sujet
qu'on évoque le rapport
améliorer le dépistage du cancer un
stage organisé ça repose sur quelque
part la direction de la santé l'inca
l'assurance maladie et du travail ont un
programme d'actions suite au rapport de
l'igas
préconise le
jeu revient pas sur le constat que vous
avez partagé à nouveau assuré des
départements confrontés à des
difficultés évidemment démographie
médicale je me permets mais c'est une
question qui requit revenus dans leurs
différentes interventions nouveau
avancé un message sur notre objectif
n'est surtout pas de faire travailler
les médecins notamment généraliste
traitant davantage ça n'est surtout pas
ça que nous voulons faire parce que hein
ça n'est pas possible
travail déjà beaucoup et ça n'est pas
l'objectif l'objectif c'est qui c'est de
les aider à faire évoluer leur
organisation pour qu' il puisse à la
fois avec une équipe prendre en charge
davantage de passants sans travailler
plus
c'est fondamentalement ça et on va vous
partager des éléments d'une étude
qualitative qu'on amenait puisqu'on est
d'aller interroger des médecins et
assistants médicaux qui avait choisi on
avait dire y compris interrogé des
médecins qui l'a pas fait et des
médecins qui ont choisi nous disent jeu
au début j'avais un peu peur parce que
en effet j'avais vaguement compris que
je devais travailler plus non je
travaille pas plus je travaille part
d'audience à mieux les patients sur
mieux pris en charge mais j'en ai sont
mieux organisés je perd moins de temps
sur des démarches administratives je
prend plus de temps avec mes patients et
donc je prends plus les chiffres pardon
du coup je reviens sur les chiffres et
des chiffres macro montre qu'à 30 mois
donc après une maturité de
l'installation des assistants médicaux à
30 mois vous avez des augmentations de
patienter de file active significative
et je le dis pardon je sais plus si vous
l'avenir s'inscrit sous ou aussi c'était
un homme sur le web est peut-être un
élément paradoxal c'est cette
augmentation de passe de file active et
de surtout de passion mais tu as tant
elle se fait y compris pour des médecins
qui avaient des patients tels très
importante déjà acquis à qui on pouvait
dire qu'ils en avaient déjà fixé des
objectifs qui étaient arrêtés pas des
objectifs d'augmentation c'était logique
d'ailleurs de maintien en disant vous
êtes déjà sur des niveaux d'activité
très élevé sincères à rien de vous
demander de faire plus vous demande
simplement quelque part de pardon de
paddy vicié de pas déposer la pac de
continuer à prier mais comme ça tu as
lorsqu'on voit aujourd'hui dans les
chiffres à 30 mois c'est ycompris cela
en fait parce que deux chauffeurs parce
que parce que ça leur fait gagner du
temps eh bien ils prennent plus de
passion donc l'idée c'est pas idéal et
pas quantitative elle est quand même de
répondre aux défis de l'accès aux soins
l'accès aux médecins traitants mais elle
est d elle et de leur permettre de
fonctionner mieux dans les meilleures
conditions et franchement je on va
vraiment vous diffusez madame la
présidente c'était une qualitatif qui
est extrêmement parlante c'est pas nous
qui le disons c'est les médecins qui
disent pardon le dire comme ça mais ma
vie mes conditions de travail ont changé
au jour où j'ai recruté 1 5401 et voilà
on l'a donc à la fois la lafa le
qualitatif et quantitatif démontre que
entre guillemets ça marche donc
maintenant commencer tout à l'heure la
question c'est comment on arrive à
vaincre notamment de réticences et là
pardon comme jeu je parle devant une
assemblée de deux sénateurs et
sénatrices y connaissent bien les
territoires bien les qualités
territoriales il ya un sujet majeur qui
a l'air tout à fait secondaire mais qui
et majeur ce sont des sujets des locaux
des locaux les médecins nous disent ce
qu'ils ne veulent pas leur premier
problème c'est je veux bien je vais
recruter réussir médical mais je ne sais
pas où je le sois et donc la question
comment nous pouvons collectivement
assurance-maladie collectivités
territoriales ars services de l'état
préfet
partenaires du logement etc trouver des
solutions attractives pour dire on est
capable de vous accompagner dans un
projet immobilier adapté et les
collectivités beaucoup de politiser le
font déjà mais de faire de façon
peut-être plus visible transparente
systématique en tous les cas voilà on à
ce sujet là et le sujet de la perte de
l'embauché et sa voile a dit oui
d'accord mais je vais embaucher
quelqu'un qu'est ce qui se passe si ça
se passe mal et si dans la et voilà des
finances et des sujets aussi qu'on veut
adresser simplifier les déclarations
sociales avec nos amis d'urssaf
éventuellement trouver les moyens comme
comme le dispositif installé en fait
c'est nous qui c'est l'assurance maladie
qui quelque part ça la vie on ne veut
pas se transformer en offre de soins
c'est pas une bonne idée j'ai pas
répondre à cette question mais on veut
pas construire nous des soins de santé
oms parce que c'est pas notre métier
mais est-ce qu'on peut être un
intermédiaire quelque part qui permet de
faciliter la mise en relation faciliter
une manière au nul de l'intervention de
l'infirmier ou l'assistance médicale
dans le cabinet du médecin ça ne semble
être extrêmement intéressant et
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue la jauge
eux je me permets là aussi de partager
le ministre l'a fait dans les dents les
mesures d'urgence cet été
continuer à soutenir les médecins qui
font du cumul emploi retraite
aujourd'hui on à 2500 médecins libéraux
qui sont en cumul un portrait 2500 c'est
significatif il faut qu'il y ait entre
guillemets évidemment de façon c'est
leur choix d'aller ramer utile qu'en
afrique continue utile de faire
connaître à nouveau les règles favorable
qui existe en matière de cotisations
sociales de droit etc il ya des
dispositifs que vous avez des invités
qui sont défavorables sont
insuffisamment connue qu'il faut
davantage soutenir et faire connaître
mais clairement c'est une ressource dont
évidemment on ne peut pas se priver
sur vous m'avez aussi interrogé sur
certains d'entre vous m'ont rappelé sur
les sur les
fauteuils roulants à lézat technique
d'abord
souligner que c'est un sujet que le
ministère a pris en main notamment suite
aux travaux qui ont été menés notamment
par philippe de normandie classes de ce
et de son rapport et que y compris des
avancées ont déjà eu lieu car mettant
notamment à travers ponctuel mais dans
la vie quotidienne
des assurés c'est important de permettre
aux anneaux thérapeute par exemple de
pouvoir prescrire des aides techniques
ces dispositifs nouveaux sur sur la
réforme entre l'évolution d'un avocat
sur des fauteuils roulants c'est un
travail qui a engagé le ministère de
deux ministères de la santé de la
direction ainsi que du social avec le
comité économique des produits de santé
beaucoup de concertation était menée
avec les fabricants les associations les
choses n'ont pas encore débouché la
problématique y compris on a pu partager
d'ailleurs les quelques semaines avec
avec avec la pf handicap sur la
réutilisation des fauteuils roulants
fait partie des sujets en discussion
pour le moment n'a pas totalement abouti
c'est aussi des modèles économiques sont
pas faciles à construire mais je pense
que dans les prochaines semaines le
ministère aura l'occasion de deux
d'avancé sur ces sujets sur ces sujets
là
juste manama sénatrice mme adams et le
double sur les
sur notamment le leu leu des sujets de
deux départs et deux finalement de
notamment d'un fermier ou d'infirmières
qui quittent la profession rapidement
ou même avant même la formation au tout
début
beaucoup de sujets que pardon le dire
comme ça pas forcément complètement en
charge l'assurance maladie ce que nous
faisons nous nous avons fait deux choses
nous avons fait qu'une chose et nous ne
sommes pas en faire un deuxième
premièrement c'est de déchets de
regarder ce qui se passe
quantitativement sur les infirmières
libérales est ce que oui ou non on a
beaucoup plus d'infirmières libérales
qui s'installe parce qu'elle viendrait
de l'hôpital du médico social en disant
j'en ai assez d'entendre mais j'aime je
vais m'inscrire libéral la réponse est
non pardon de le dire comme ça on ne
voit pas de choses de rupture dans la
tendance voilà 2002 il a rien
d'extraordinaire trimix on a regardé
dans l'autre sens est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'infirmières libérales qui
aida aussi arrête parce que l on aura
entre gay mais elle a dû s'y d'ailleurs
elles ont des horaires de travail très
lourd et des temps de travail
hebdomadaire très lourd là non plus on
ne voit pas de rupture de tendance
significative on n'a pas l'impression
qu'en tout cas sur le monde libéral
espace des choses qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire quand même un de lancer
un travail plus qualitatif pour quand
même interrogés seuls qui sont partis
qui ont raté leur activité avant le
départ à la retraite pour essayer de
comprendre pourquoi voilà donc on va
regarder un échantillon de ceux qui sont
partis
dernière au début d'année à douala entre
guillemets pourquoi vous êtes parti de
mener un certain nombre d' enquêtes
qualitatives procès de comprendre je
crois que le ministère travaille de son
côté aussi le même type de démarche
c'est de comprendre ce qui se passe à
l'hôpital au delà d'un phénomène encore
une fois qui est mondial en réalité de
départ et de ras-le-bol ou de fatigue
qui fait que les gens posent leurs
tabliers leur bout de temps voilà j'en
ai marre j'arrêterai ce que c'est mais
en même temps on voit bien ça peut ne
pas non plus difficilement pérenne
toutes les infirmières de ce pays vont
pas se reconvertir tous les soignants
demandé d'un nouveau métier tant mieux
si elles le souhaitent exercer leur
choix mais on voit bien que on a besoin
de comprendre le phénomène nous dans le
libéral on est en train d'être à quatre
quantitativement on voit rien l'histoire
de changement qualitativement il faut
quand même mieux comprendre et sans
doute essayer de regarder dès lors qu'on
aura mieux compris quand même pourquoi
des infirmières libérales arrêtent de
travailler qu'est ce qui peut faire pour
essayer de proposer à nouveau qu'elle
entre guillemets qu'elle dit reviennent
en tout cas et de faire que ceux qui
restent il reste encore davantage on a
quand même deux puissances avaient
soutenu beaucoup le métier d'infirmier
limal dans ce pays continuer à le faire
mais y compris dans des amants récent
sur le bsi on l'a on l'a on a fait
s'agissant des
menaces la sénatrice jacques mais le leu
leu sur la redevance d'examen je rejoins
bien volontiers d'ailleurs dans le
rapport là encore j'y reviens sa
biologie à une étude très intéressante
non si c'est vous permettre ne vous
arrêtez pas la synthèse n'hésitez pas à
regarder le monde le rapport lui-même il
ya une étude très approfondie sur
l'évolution de volume d'actes de
biologie dans notre pays qui montre que
notamment entre 2021 2019 on a le plus
subi % d'augmentation du nombre de
prescriptions de goji de par ordonnance
lui pour cent vingt deux ans honnêtement
dire aucun rationnelle de santé publique
et le justifie comment on fait pas ça on
scénario morgan on veut enclencher une
discussion d'une nouvelle convention
avec les biologistes travailler avec les
médecins prescripteurs et les
biologistes sur la qualité de la
prescription il ya déjà des travaux qui
ont été engagées on veut les
prochaines avec nos amis biologiste à ce
sujet et voilà même chose sur la
pertinence la redondance un certain
nombre d'examens de radiologie vous avez
présidente c'est des chantiers qu'on
avait qu'on a honnêtement mais un peu en
sommeil avec la crise qui était dans le
protocole plus rien avec les radiologues
mais qu'on veut créer un plancher dans
le rapport vous avez aussi des
chaussures là exactement la redondance
mais la bonne utilisation des produits
de contraste en radiologie on paye très
cher aujourd'hui dans notre pays
globalement les produits de contraste
beaucoup de volume beaucoup de
gaspillage un conditionnement inefficace
il faut on y reviennent
sur le sénateur sur le transport des
enfants handicapés au global d'ailleurs
je le retiens que le sujet d'accès aux
soins des personnes handicapées pour
nous un sujet majeur on a fait des
choses en avant neuf avec un médecin
dentiste sur la meilleure prise en
charge des personnes handicapées on va
faire des choses avec la convention
médicale à la rentrée je plonge devant
le cncph vendredi on a intégré toutes
les équipes de pascal jacob sur andy
faction le baromètre d'accès aux soins
des personnes handicapées que la science
mady a repris quelques elle va
maintenant publier régulièrement donc
c'est vraiment un sujet majeur tout à
fait preneur de voir avec vous sur des
sujets sur des sujets on n'avançait pas
refaire des territoriaux patients sur la
prise en charge des transports pour les
enfants handicapés sur la carte vitale
biométrique vous confirmez
vous confirmer le fait qu' on a engagé
une expérimentation pour des matériaux
et la carte vitale mettre la carte
vitale sur votre smartphone
permettre de ne faire que du coup vous
allez des malchances de la paire de deux
entraînements de
on à l'expérimentation
de territoire en 2019 2020 2021 là aussi
c'était un peu chahuté par la crise les
enseignements sont on l'a fait avec
quelques dixièmes de deux médecins et
deux et de problèmes de santé ça
fonctionne en tout cas le processus
d'enrôlement des personnes qui permet de
vérifier leur identité avec une
vérification de leurs la concordance
entre le la pièce d'identité et une
reconnaissance faciale au moment de
l'enrôlement fonctionne
et donc on s'arrange s'apprête à
déployer plus largement cette
expérimentation dans le département à la
rentrée
dans un contexte plus général vous savez
que le ministre de la santé hier
devant l'assemblée nationale a évoqué le
fait qu'il sera utile qu'une mission ce
soit soit lancé sur ce sujet là pour
voilà la phrase voir les conditions dans
lesquelles cette ce dispositif là se
lance et voir s'il faut aller au delà
sur 7 sur cette carte vitale
utilisant de la biométrie
sera évidemment partie prenante de cette
mission si elle se confirme en ayant
aussi en tête à la fois bien sûr
les impératifs de lutte contre la fraude
est aussi là comment dirais je
l'intégration de ces évolutions dues aux
métriques dans la pratique de soins
prochaine santé qui nous disent que leur
rôle n'est pas fondamentalement d'abord
de l'identité des gens mais d'avant on
peut soigner donc il faut tout de même
vérifier que
cette utilisation de la biométrie
s'intègre bien dans un
processus fluide
s'agissant peut-être madame la
présidente j'ai répondu grâce aux
assistants médicaux nous confirme bien
notre volonté de déverrouiller en tout
cas d'être soupire le système sur le sur
la greffe le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand précédent avait eu
l'occasion de le lancer que deux
semaines avant son départ un plan greffe
doté de 210 millions d'euros auxquels
nous avons participé on a est compris
dans le cadre des travaux préparatoires
mener des études de
médico économique sur la base de la
greffière socialiste a fait s'il en est
qui ont sous-tendu un certain nombre des
mesures de ce plan sur le riz h m vous
confirmez que on a travaillé avec la
haute autorité de santé pour que
notamment à la rentrée la haute autorité
de santé puisse
engager
priorisation des travaux sur la base des
des retours avec les différentes cmp
pour voilà c'est quand c'est le travail
et
identifiés notamment d'examen
prioritaire et que de notre côté dans le
travail avec les biologistes on a bien
en tête d'identifier d identifier des
enveloppes qui permettrait la bascule et
défis des financements et la chaîne
notamment à l'hôpital vers la ville
voilà et pour faire ça il faut que l'on
ait fait un travail d'évaluation qui
s'engagent mais beaucoup travaillé ces
derniers mois qui devrait vous permettre
de s'engager plus fortement si on a un
programme de travail engagé à la rentrée
je m'aperçois que je n'ai pas répondu
sur la presse qui nous a travaillé bien
se redire que la pression dans le
travail n'est pas réservé aux médecins
traitants donc ça n'est pas inscrit
glisse aujourd'hui ça ne passe que nous
proposons demain ou simplement qu' il
n'y a plus assez de gens n'arrêtent pas
c'est les consultations signer si ce
n'est pas votre médecin traitant si vous
les femmes est sympa on pourra toujours
aller voir un médecin physiquement
présentes et puis je ne rebondit pas sur
les données de santé puisque vous
évoquez futures missions du futur
audition mais je l'évoqué sur datta
pathologie on est très engagé dans
l'ouverture des données santé avec nos
habituels de pub ce qu'on a fait sur la
vaccination sur le data vaccin collins
qu'on fait sur d'autres pathologies ce
qu'on fait sur l'ippi phare avec nos
amis de la rsm sur toutes les études qui
ont été menées depuis maintenant un an
sur la vaccination sont liés à
l'utilisation des données du srd à
l'ouverture de santé mais beaucoup
d'autres exemples qui ont agi avec vous
s'il va auditionner sur ce sujet hyper
quoi les services communs pas répondu
sur l'hypercholestérolémie familiale
s'il y avait des mesures qu'elle est
prise parce que ce comme on dit
l'association
c'est qu'ils avaient un article 51 en
paca d'un dispositif
mais qui était sur du dépistage de
cascades mais qu aurait eu un refus de
la cnam
sur le r et achêne ça fait quand même 57
sur quoi on va y arriver mais c'est à
dire c'est tellement mentalement
annuellement voilà un point très
rapidement
oui merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le directeur général c'est
juste sur le la nécessité d'avoir des
réseaux pour permettre à beaucoup de
deux professionnels de santé de
dialoguer de façon à ce que
faciliter l'accès aux soins des patients
ville hôpital ou aux réseaux plus
spécifiques par exemple les réseaux dans
son logis terry santé a vécu il n'a pas
vraiment été très utilisé il n'est pas
assez agile est-ce que vous avez autre
chose pour le remplacer parce que c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très important
de permettre
aux professionnels de santé de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux patients et
c'est surtout en oncologie
sur terry santé skate au sens yonne
travail de déploiement avec ars
ile-de-france le ministère la santé sur
le l'intégration de cette plateforme
dans le temps tout le programme de
numérique en santé notamment le
déploiement de mon espace santé vraiment
je pense fondamentalement le
répondre précisément le lors qu'on aura
déployé un espace santé bourse ou
d'assurer avec une messagerie de santé
entre les assurés et les projets de
santé à une messagerie sécurisée santé
qui se développent également entre les
professionnels santé on aura construit
une bonne partie dès lors que cet espace
santé sera nourri c'était avec les
biologistes on avance vite sur
l'alimentation systématique de des
résultats de biologie dans mon espace
santé et dans le dmp pour l'accès au
médecin traitant on avance également été
radiologue pour lequel compte rendus de
radiologie sortent également
automatiquement dans mon espace santé
dans le dmp le compte rendu de ce kit
alisation ça avance également rapidement
beaucoup de juges sont en train de
basculer progressivement avec une
alimentation cinématiques y compris le
plus grand d'entre eux en ile de france
des comptes rendus d'hospitalisation
dans mon espace santé donc voilà quelque
part on est en train de vraiment de
construire les bases pour que ça marche
après on a des outils entre guillemets
de e-parcours de plateformes
territoriales qui existent qu'il faut
progressivement intégrées dans des
systèmes interopérables mais je crois
que la feuille de route du numérique ont
certes elle permet ça et que ça va ça va
se mettre en place dans les prochains
mois oui c'est surtout le dialogue entre
les professionnels de santé qui est
important mais ça fait partie on ne fait
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
pour cette ces deux heures de des
changes était important pour nous et on
se reverra bien évidemment pour voir si
tout ça se traduit dans le plfss
les pères vous